aber
es
ist
eine
gute
Idee.
Ich
hoffe
ihr habt
viel
Spaß
damit
und
ich
hoffe
wir sehen
uns
bald
wieder.
Tschüss.
Falsch, falsch.
Ah, jetzt schon.
Äh, Moment.
Half-Life 1.
Kann man die Kategorie umstellen.
So.
Excellent, excellent.
Ja.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Ich hab gerade ein Video hochgeladen.
Nur für den Fall, auf YouTube, nur für den Fall,
dass euch irgendjemand nicht gesehen hat.
Es könnte auch sein, dass euch das Thema nicht interessiert, das ist ja in Ordnung, aber vielleicht wisst ihr es auch gar nicht.
Ja, habe ich, vor viertel Stunde oder so, guck hier, YouTube, äh, hallo, what the fuck, Max, äh, äh, ja, ja, genau.
Wenn man seinen eigenen Channel nicht richtig schreiben kann, hier tatsächlich, ich habe ein Video hochgeladen, mal wieder, seit, glaub, vor 25 Tagen oder so war das letzte Video.
Schreiben die Leute, denn ich habe die Comments jetzt schon ein paar Minuten nicht gelesen.
Ich würde nie mehr als 4 Tage in einer Woche arbeiten. 5 Tage in der Woche bieten mir zu viel die Ohren an.
Ja, sehe ich genauso.
Ja, es ist übrigens, ich habe eine...
Ja gut, da kann man nichts machen.
Eine Sache ist mir aufgefallen, muss ich euch jetzt gerade nochmal zeigen, was hier jemand vorgerechnet hat.
Und zwar, guckt mal, meint ihr das stimmt?
das müsste man mal ausrechnen. Und zwar, er hat hier geschrieben,
äh, bla bla bla bla, ausrechnen, bla bla bla bla, hier genau.
Er hat gesagt, eine 5-Tage-Woche bedeutet in Deutschland ungefähr ein Verhältnis von 60% Arbeitstage versus 40% freie Tage.
Und eine 4-Tage-Woche bedeutet in Deutschland ungefähr ein Verhältnis von 45% Arbeitstage, also 45% Arbeitstage zu 55% freie Tage.
Und das heißt, durch den einen Tag bekommt man quasi mehr freie Tage als Arbeitstage, also das Verhältnis hin.
War mir überhaupt nicht klar.
Man müsste das echt mal ausrechnen.
Ich bin mir ja so auf den ersten...
Weiß nicht, ich komm mir erst mal komisch vor, aber kann durchaus sein.
Also das fand ich tatsächlich ganz interessant.
Da hätte ich gar nicht dran gedacht, dass das so sein könnte.
Arbeitet ihr auch wirklich in der Summe weniger oder arbeitet ihr quasi 10 Stunden am Tag
und dafür nur 4 Tage?
Oder keine Ahnung 9,5 oder so, weil ganz ehrlich gerade auf dem Bau könnte ich mir
das auch sehr schwierig vorstellen.
Also wie will man das machen 10 Stunden am Tag?
Also ganz ehrlich, die Diskussion gibt es ja überall aktuell.
Letztens hat sogar unser Arbeitsminister irgendwas zugesagt, so 4-Tage-Woche, super Idee.
Die diskutieren alle aber zum größten Teil über die 4-Tage-Arbeitswoche mit kompletter,
mit gleichbleibender Arbeitszeit
und ob
das so geil ist, weiß ich nicht
wenn ich mir vorstelle
ich möchte 10 Tage am Tag da arbeiten
das wäre für mich nix
mit Urlaubstagen, ja klar mit Urlaubstagen
mit Urlaubstagen und Feiertagen, das ist schon klar
Doch, man darf mehr als 8 Stunden arbeiten im Durchschnitt. Ich glaube, du darfst nicht mehr als 10 Stunden arbeiten und du musst 11 Stunden zwischen Arbeitsende und Arbeitsbeginn haben.
Ich glaube, das sind die einzigen Vorschriften, die es da gibt.
Ja genau, so hab ich das auch im Kopf. Du darfst nicht länger als 10 Stunden am Tag arbeiten und du musst zwischen Arbeitsende und Arbeitsbeginn 11 Stunden einmal am Stück Pause haben.
Ja gut, es ist ja gut, dass wir in Deutschland so Regelungen haben.
Ja gut, das kommt noch dazu.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte mir im Kopf, dass du an manchen Tagen nicht länger, also dass
du insgesamt nicht länger als 10 Stunden arbeiten darfst, sonst gibt es irgendwie Probleme.
Steiner hat lange für den Zap gar nicht gesehen, aber ansonsten ist ja gut, dass wir in Deutschland so Regelungen haben, ich meine...
Leute arbeiten schon genug.
Ne, mein Fall wär das tatsächlich auch nicht.
Yuki, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Mein Fall wär's tatsächlich auch nicht.
Weil, ich wüsste gar nicht, also ich kann mich schon nicht 8 Stunden richtig konzentrieren, ja?
Weißt du gar nicht, wie ich das mit 10 Stunden machen sollte?
Also, ich denke tatsächlich, dass die Zukunft, und das wird, ich mein, an den Diskussionen sieht man's doch schon.
Das wird die nächsten Jahre über immer weiter zunehmen, dass immer mehr Leute 4 Tage Woche arbeiten.
Und, was, also den Eindruck, den ich hab, ich kann's euch nicht bestätigen, weil ich gehöre zwar nicht direkt zu der Generation dabei,
Aber ich habe den Eindruck, dass die Generation jetzt quasi
nach mir, wenn nicht sogar zwei nach mir, also die, die jetzt quasi anfangen zu
arbeiten und gerade
angefangen haben zu arbeiten,
also bei den jungen Leuten, sagen wir mal so 20, 20, um 20 Jahre rum,
ich glaube die haben gar keinen Bock mehr
5 Tage die Woche, 8 Stunden am Tag durchgängig zu arbeiten. Ich glaube die
setzen ihre Prioritäten noch anders
als meine Generation und noch mal ganz anders als die Generation davor.
Weil mal ganz im Ernst, bei der Generation vor mir,
also, ähm,
so quasi meine Eltern im Endeffekt, ja,
da war es ja eigentlich fast normal,
dass dein Lebensinhalt war,
arbeiten gehen und krass Karriere machen, zumindest bei vielen Männern war das der Fall,
für die war quasi Karriere machen so das Geilste, was man im Leben erreichen kann.
Und, ähm,
insgesamt,
Also ich glaube, ich bilde mir zumindest ein, dass das die Generation heute, die jetzt quasi anfängt zu arbeiten, auch die, die jetzt schon angefangen hat zu arbeiten, teilweise auch inklusive meiner Generation schon.
Bei meiner hat sich so ein bisschen angefangen, das zu wandeln. Manche sind so richtig, du merkst es extrem.
Also ich glaube, meine Generation ist ziemlich zweigespalten, generell. Also nicht so sehr, nicht nur was die Einstellung angeht zu, man lebt nur um arbeiten zu gehen, sondern generell.
Es gibt Leute in... Was ist denn meine Generation? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das nennt.
Ypsilon?
Oder so?
Was auch immer.
Nicht wirklich die Boomer-Generation, aber das, wo man immer Boomer zu sagt.
Also quasi, ich würde mal sagen, so Leute zwischen jetzt 35 und 45 irgendwie so, ja?
Und, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt auch 38, 38 gerade.
Und werde dieses Jahr 39.
Man merkt bei meiner Generation ganz extrem, es gibt Leute, die sind Ultra-Boomer, die sind quasi komplett schon wie die Generation davor
und es gibt Leute, die sind irgendwie gefühlt noch gar nicht so alt.
So und ich glaube das liegt an einem ganz einschneidenden, wie soll man sagen, an einer ganz einschneidenden Weggabelung, die die in ihrem Leben getroffen haben,
haben, nämlich die Leute, also ich kann das nur von meiner Erfahrung berichten, die Leute,
die mit Technik, Internet, Computer und sowas was am Hut haben, die sind eigentlich nicht
wirklich richtig Boomer geworden, obwohl sie schon 38, 39, 40 sind.
Die Leute, die damals gesagt haben, ah, geh mir weg mit dem Technik-Scheiß, das sind
heute die boomerischsten Boomer ever, die beim Stammtisch sitzen und irgendwie über
die Welt philosophieren, wie geil sie bescheid wissen und keiner das macht, was sie sagen.
Also, das ist zumindest mein persönlicher Eindruck, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das wirklich stimmt, aber es gab halt gerade, bei meiner Generation
war es halt nun mal so, so im Alter von, sagen wir mal so 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, je nachdem
Wie alt die Leute damals gewesen sind, als es dann langsam salonfähig wurde, Computer daheim zu haben, Internetanschluss daheim zu haben und das ist immer weiter.
Da gibt's Leute, die sind halt auf diesen Techniktrend aufgesprungen und das hat die irgendwie auch ein bisschen jung gehalten.
Vor allem hat man so ein bisschen so weiterhin Kontakt auch im Internet, dass man so mitbekommt, so der Zeitgeist der jüngeren Generation und sowas.
Und die, die das nicht mitbekommen haben, die kaufen sich morgens immer noch die Bild am Kiosk und meckern, meckern den ganzen Tag rum.
Also, du hast Leute mit 39, 38, 39 heute, die sind so krass Boomer, so ungefähr wie mein Opa, und du hast welche, ja, die sind's halt wahrscheinlich eher so ein bisschen wie ich.
Ich führe das darauf zurück, ob die damals mit Technik aufgewachsen sind und sich dafür
interessiert haben oder nicht.
Alle, die gesagt haben, Computer und Technik und Internet und so ein neumodiger Scheiß
und das braucht man nicht, die sind heute alles mega boomerische Boomer und die anderen
die sind noch halbwegs gut dabei.
Ja gut, Haus kaufen ist auch echt in Deutschland voll für den Arsch, also ich hab's gesehen,
ich hab's ja im Video heute gesagt, ich hab's ja bei einem meiner ehemaligen Ex-Kollegen
mitgekriegt, der ist ein bisschen jünger, ich glaub da war, als ich da weg bin, ich
glaub der war irgendwie 29, 28, 29, der war ungefähr 10, 5, 5 bis, ja sagen wir mal 10
ähm, Frau, Kind und die haben sich jetzt ein Haus gekauft und die haben die Planung gehabt, ja, ich sag mal, da war um die 30, sagen wir mal so ungefähr, der hat geplant, die haben sich ein Haus gekauft und die haben geplant für 30 Jahre das abzubezahlen.
Alter, ich weiß nicht mal was in 5 Jahren ist, geschweige denn was machen die denn?
Gut, vielleicht mache ich mir auch viel zu viele Gedanken um sowas, deswegen habe ich auch keine Kinder, heirate nicht und kaufe keine Häuser und sowas.
Kann ja auch sein, dass ich da einfach zu viel Bedenken habe, aber
ähm, ich, ich sehe es einfach nicht so, weil, wie gesagt, ich weiß schon nicht, was in fünf Jahren ist
und, und was in 30 Jahren ist, schon mal gar nicht.
Ich kann abgekratzt sein bis dahin, ähm, man hat keinen Bock mehr aufeinander, lässt sich scheiden und sonst wie, was machst du damit?
Ich würde im Leben keinen Kredit aufnehmen für 30 Jahre Laufzeit, Alter, das ist jetzt...
Also ich nehme prinzipiell keine Kredite auf, aber für 30 Jahre Laufzeit schon mal gar nicht.
Du hast 40 Jahre Arbeitskredit nicht mehr in den Händen...
Ja, genau das meine ich.
Ja, ja, korrekt.
Die Leute, die dann auch sagen so nach dem Motto, oh Smartphone so ein Kack so, das ist mir nix und Social Media ist ganz böse und...
Gibt's ja Leute, die sind tatsächlich so der Meinung.
Also muss man wirklich sagen, Social Media ist für'n Arsch, also wie die Leute da miteinander umgehen, beziehungsweise wie manche Leute da so in die Falle tappen, so nach dem Motto, dass sie sich permanent mit irgendwelchen Influencer-Leuten vergleichen müssen.
Es gibt ja, es gibt sogar mittlerweile Krankheitsbezeichnungen dafür, dass wenn die Leute auf ihren Follower-Account auf Twitter oder auf YouTube oder TikTok oder so gucken und der Follower-Account ist gedroppt oder irgendwie der Like-Account ist gedroppt, dann geht's denen schlecht so den Tag über bis dann wieder irgendwie paar Likes.
Da gibt's ja tatsächlich mittlerweile schon Krankheitsbezeichnungen für. Also das ist ziemlich für'n Arsch.
Das heißt allerdings nicht, dass es nicht auch eine sinnvolle Seite haben kann, ja?
Das ganze Rumgeflame auf Twitter und das dumme Geschwätze, das ist dämlich, aber es hat ja durchaus auch seinen Sinn.
Ich meine, gerade bei Twitter ist der Vorteil offensichtlich. Ich glaube, du kriegst nirgendwo so schnell mit, wenn irgendwie was passiert.
Eventuell auch noch aus den Gebieten, was dich persönlich betrifft oder was dich persönlich interessiert, wie auf Twitter.
Das ist ein unglaublicher Vorteil. Früher musstest du warten, bis man irgendeine Nachrichtenseite darüber geschrieben hat oder sowas.
Ja, das ist halt ein bisschen für den Arsch, dass es in Deutschland nicht so gut geht mit
den Häusern.
Ich mein, ich hab mal vor einer Weile ein Video geguckt, wie gesagt, was so Finanzberatungsanlage
Zeug geht, bin ich jetzt nicht so der Pro, aber die haben gesagt, dass es sich in den
meisten Ländern lohnt ein Haus zu bauen, weil die Leute dann quasi mehr oder weniger
das, was sie sonst für die Miete bezahlen würden, quasi benutzen können, um ihren Kredit abzubezahlen, und wenn sie das dann abbezahlt haben, gehört es ihnen halt.
Also, im Prinzip eigentlich nur von Vorteil. So, und das wäre wohl in nahezu jedem Land so, nur in Deutschland würde es sich nicht lohnen.
Oder, Deutschland ist eines der wenigen Länder, wo es sich nicht lohnt, auf diese Art und Weise ein Haus zu kaufen.
Ich kann es weder bestätigen noch, keine Ahnung, entstetigen, weil ich von so Finanzanlage-Sachen wenig Ahnung habe.
Und gut, ich mein ich hab das Problem auch nicht, wir haben das Haus vom Opa, aber klang schon logisch.
Ja.
Ja gut, ohne Geld geht's halt nicht, ne? Das ist halt... So ist es halt. Ohne Kohle klappt das nicht.
Ich mein, ich hab's insofern ganz gut. Ich hab keine Kinder oder irgendwie sonst wie was, wo ich großartige finanzielle Verpflichtungen hätte und ich geb halt eigentlich auch einfach kein Geld aus.
Ich gebe halt, guck mal Leute, für was gebe ich Geld aus?
Ich gebe für alle 5 Jahre mal Geld, bisschen für den Rechner aus.
Okay, letztes Jahr tatsächlich, ich habe mir seit 20 Jahren oder so mal wieder ein Auto gekauft.
Oder seit 15 Jahren oder irgendwie, ist auf jeden Fall schon lange her.
Ich habe mir ein Auto gekauft, also insofern, ich gebe ja eigentlich auch noch kaum Geld aus.
Aber ich meine, ich muss ja auch nicht, ich muss ja auch keine Familie versorgen, Kinder versorgen oder sonst was, wo man halt die Geld...
Ja gut, Stonks hab ich tatsächlich.
Ich müsste grad mal gucken, wie meine Stonks laufen.
Ach, wahrscheinlich, jetzt hat sich nicht plus, minus, nicht so viel getan.
Stonks hab ich tatsächlich.
Ja gut, irgendwo muss ich ja mit der Kohle hin.
Aber ETF-Stonks, nichts sonderlich risikoreiches.
Falls jemand fragt.
Ja Leute, so, wir spielen heute Half-Life weiter.
Stonks gingen gestern richtig ab.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Ne, es hat sich quasi im Lauf des Jahres nicht allzu viel getan mit Stonks.
Na immerhin!
Immerhin!
Es ist... vorbei?
Hä, was ist das für ne Kackseite, man?
Die Stonks gingen tatsächlich recht gut rauf.
Ich muss mal nachher in die App gucken, Stonks ist das Beste, Stonks, Aktien, ich guck mal
kurz ins Handy, warte mal, ich muss mal kurz Scalable aufmachen und meine Stonks angucken.
äh...
ähm...
hm...
oh ne, es hat sich wieder ausgelockt
die App suckt auch richtig, alter
ah ne
ich hab mein Passwort gespeichert, ok, nice
oh, oh, die Stocks
gingen aber richtig, alter
diesen Monat plus 1113 Euro
Euro. BigStonks. QuickMaths. Und Amazon? Amazon gegen diesen Monat einfach mal 20%. Nice.
Pogostonks. Schon 2FA-Login in Scalable aktiviert. Ja.
Gibt's noch nicht so lange.
Nice!
Ja, Chat, gut, dass ihr Bescheid gesagt habt.
Jetzt weiß ich, dass ich plus 4,45% in diesem Monat gemacht habe, meinen Stonks.
Aber nachdem ich ja meine Stonks nicht verkaufe, hab ich die im Endeffekt ja nicht wirklich,
also wenn es jetzt wieder runter geht, ist es halt wieder weg.
Aber wir hoffen natürlich drauf, dass es nur noch rauf geht.
Bis ich es dann irgendwann mal an mir ausbezahlen lasse.
Big Strongs Wieder Plus Minus Null, ne es ist mehr als
Null.
Ich kann mal gucken.
Ne, es ist, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, es ist, wo steht es denn, plus ein Jahr, plus seins,
Also ich habe es für das für das Jahr im Jahr ist es auch plus 100 1136
Today Moment Moment Allein Heute sind die stocks um 477 euro als was ging was war Denn
Was war habe ich irgendwas verpasst warum sind die stocks so krass abgegangen
Wie sieht man bei scale aber den gewinn in prozent du kannst einstellen
Wieso direkt auf der Startseite siehst du das?
Das steht direkt auf der Startseite.
Da steht Portfolio.
Oh, und dann kannst du auswählen.
Das Jahr, seit dem Kauf, seit gestern, seit Woche.
Das steht direkt auf der Startseite.
Ganz ehrlich, reich werden muss man nicht.
Wichtig ist, dass man genug Geld hat, dass man das machen kann, worauf man Bock hat.
Dass man das natürlich nicht so zu 100% alles immer ausleben kann, was man sich zu 100% wünscht, ja, das ist das eine.
Aber ich find's halt ein Unding, dass es Leute gibt, die 40 Stunden die Woche schaffen müssen und am Ende des Monats plus minus Null auf dem Konto sind.
Und die quasi arbeiten gehen und nichts, was sie quasi so erfüllt und wo sie Bock drauf haben und was sie sich wünschen, je machen können davon.
Das ist halt richtig von Arsch. Das finde ich kacke, dass es da zunehmend Leute gibt.
Ich habe letztens erst wieder so ein Diagramm gesehen, ich glaube beim Spiegel oder so, mit...
Oh, wie ist das? Es gibt ja so Geschichten mit Durchschnittsgehalt, nee, irgendwie Mediangehalt, Durchschnittsgehalt und bereinigtes, ganz komisches, ich krieg's aus dem Kopf nicht zusammen, wie der Campbell heißt.
Zumindest ist es, also man ist quasi reich in Anführungsstrichen bei viel weniger als man eigentlich denkt.
Also, wenn man mal reich definiert, sodass man quasi zu den 10% der Leute gehört, die mehr verdienen als der Rest.
Das ist viel weniger, als man denkt.
Das war mir im Vorfeld auch so nicht bewusst.
AI-Hype bei Big Tech und einigen Menüs.
Aha.
Systema.
Ich hoffe, die einigen sich weiter, dass die Stonks raufgehen.
So, Leute.
Wir spielen noch in Half-Life weiter.
Übrigens, wisst ihr, was ich gerne nach Half-Life 4 im Stream nochmal durchspielen würde?
Beziehungsweise ich hab's ja noch gar nicht durchgespielt, falls jemand, falls jemand mein Video heute gesehen hat
Und das Game noch nicht kennt, das
Es gibt tatsächlich mal ein gutes
Warhammer Game. Ich weiß, ich weiß eh nicht was Wizards of the Coast macht oder ne, ne, ne, nicht Wizards of the Coast
Von wem ist Warhammer?
Game Workshop oder?
Games Workshop.
Äh, jetzt hab ich mich grad vertan.
Ähm...
Äh, jetzt hab ich mich vertan.
Ähm, mich wundert's eh,
dass es so wenig gescheite Warhammer
Games gibt. So, und wer so
auf so ein bisschen Retro-Shooter-Sachen steht,
oder wie das auch neuerdings liebevoll so genannt
wird, Boomer-Shooter,
was ich ja persönlich eine ganz nice Bezeichnung finde,
weil es trifft sich einfach, ja.
Ich bin genau in dem Alter, mir gefallen so Games, das Game dauert nicht lang.
Das würde ich auch gerne on Stream nochmal spielen, weil es macht mega Bock das Kampfsystem.
Es hat ein paar Probleme, Trefferfeedback ist nicht so geil.
Aber ich finde die Optik, ich finde die Optik nice.
Gerade halt, wenn man eben so aus der Zeit kommt von, ja von Quake und Half-Life und so, dann mag man solche, solche Retro-Optik.
Und das Gameplay macht Bock.
Das würde ich, das würde ich gerne im Stream auch nochmal schnell durchflitzen.
Dauert wahrscheinlich drei stunden oder so erstmal durch. Geht relativ zackig, wenn man die Level kennt.
Doch, ja. Irgendsowas habe ich auch letztes gehört.
Was ich, was ich lustig fand.
Also, erste mal muss ich sagen, ich fand die Witcher Serie schon nicht sonderlich geil.
Also,
Das man konnte sich durchaus geben, aber
Es ist so die hohe kunst war das nicht
Also es war vor allem sehr
Unlogisch an vielen stellen nur gut
Was ich da aber halbwitzig fand dass also eines der besten sachen für mich in der witcher witcher serie war tatsächlich der hauptdarsteller
Ich finde da das wirklich gut gemacht. Ich habe ursprünglich
Als ich den den ersten diesen ersten mini teaser damals gesehen habe
Habe ich gedacht, der passt doch überhaupt nicht als Geralt, aber ich muss sagen, das war eines der besten Sachen an der ganzen Serie und naja, im Endeffekt ist die Serie nicht so gut eingeschlagen, wie man sich das vorgestellt hat, beziehungsweise auch so von Kritiken her und auch von Fans her kam das jetzt nicht allzu gut an.
Zumindest nach der dritten Staffel ist er jetzt ja ausgestiegen oder wurde gekickt oder was auch immer.
was auch immer. Und wisst ihr worauf ich raus bin? Wisst ihr was ich witzig fand? Es haben
sich Leute bei ihm beschwert während des Drehs, dass er so stinkige Furze lassen würde
immer am Set. Hab ich mir gedacht, okay, es mag ja sein, es mag ja sein, dass ihr Probleme
hatte, dass euer Hauptdarsteller euch zu furzt. Aber ich meine ernsthaft, ist das irgendwas,
was man in einem öffentlichen Interview erzählen muss? Kann man nicht einfach mal die Fresse
halten, Alter? Muss man das seriously in einem Interview sagen? Man hatte Probleme mit dem
Hauptdarsteller, weil er immer so stinkig gefurzt hat? Ich meine, der Typ ist eh, ich
überlegbar. Wo findest du das in Kombination? Ja, so den übertriebenen Bodybuilder-Sigma-Chat-Typ,
der dann auch noch Ahnung vom Source-Material hat und nicht nur Ahnung, der sich dafür auch noch
interessiert und Lore-Ahnung hat und alles mögliche. Das ist doch eine Kombination,
Die gibt's eigentlich gar nicht normalerweise.
Also wenn der ein bisschen was zu sagen hat bei der Warhammer Serie, könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das was taugt.
Na gut, in der ersten Staffel hat er ja quasi nur mürrisch geguckt und irgendwie 5000 mal fuck gesagt.
Hast du schon mal was mit Blazer gemacht?
Gemacht ist zu viel des Guten
Also wir haben
Tatsächlich mal vor vier Jahren und vor zwei Jahren und und sowas ein bisschen was mit Blazer
gebastelt. Ich muss aber sagen mir hat es nicht gefallen und mich überzeugt auch
Blazer an sich nicht sonderlich
Keine Ahnung was da gelaufen ist, ich fand bloß die Story mit dem, dass er angeblich
gefurzt hat am Set lustig.
So.
Dann gucken wir uns mal Half-Life an, zweite Hälfte.
HTTPS Quickstart, ne, nicht HTTPS Quickstart.
Also wir sind das letzte Mal stehen geblieben, weil ich muss mal kurz hier umstellen.
Und wir müssen mal schnell die Lautstärke testen, ob die Lautstärke passt.
Sagt mir mal, ob das alles okay so ist?
Müsste eigentlich so passen, ja?
Vielleicht ein bisschen laut?
Warte mal, lass mich mal kurz was checken.
Volume Mixer, ne, das ist richtig.
Das ist genau die richtigen Sound Settings vom letzten Mal auch.
ist eigentlich, ist eigentlich gut
Ne, ich glaube, ich glaube, wenn ich rede dabei, ist es eigentlich ganz, ganz passend so, guck mal
Lass mal hier vergleichen, ich glaub das...
Warte mal
Warum ist es immer so schwierig?
Soundlautstärke in Windows
Ja, wir können, wir können ein, ein Tick, wir können ein Tick noch leiser machen, so 1, 1% oder so
Genau, also wir sind stehenge...
Da wollte ich... Oh, kann man die Dinger...
Wait a minute, man kann die Dinger platt hauen!
Leute, Fish AI!
Oh.
Das war jetzt ziemlich bescheuert, jetzt bin ich fast abgesoffen.
Also, wir sind halt vor einiger Stelle stehen geblieben. Vielleicht soll ich nochmal kurz was zum Modges sagen.
Wir spielen nämlich nicht einfach Half-Life 1, wir spielen Half-Life 1...
Ähm, M-Mod.
Und zwar Half-Life 1 M-Mod. Ich schalte nochmal kurz um auf den Desktop.
Half-Life 1 M-Mod.
Zack, gibt es kostenlos bei Steam.
Also wenn man Bock hat, Half-Life wieder zu spielen, bzw. wer Half-Life 1 noch nie gespielt hat,
dem kann ich das wärmste empfehlen, sich das auch gleich mit M-Mod anzugucken.
zu gucken. Ich meine, das Ding hat nicht umsonst hier übertrieben positive Bewertungen. Und zwar, was haben die bei M-Mod gemacht?
Mal gucken, die hatten doch selbst eine Liste, genau. Also sie haben das Original-Game genommen und versucht das quasi so im Sinne des Erfinders
ein bisschen zu erweitern. Also sprich, man hat neue Waffen, man hat neue Schussmodi für die Waffen, man hat beispielsweise auch, ja guck mal,
Man hat beispielsweise auch fürs Brecheisen, das ist jetzt neu, das gab es im Original nicht.
Fürs Brecheisen hat man jetzt so einen Powerschlag, Sekundärmodus und sogar noch eine dritte Attacke,
dass man das aufladen kann und damit hauen.
Weil normalerweise hat man den Brecheisen ja immer nur gemacht.
So und das hat viele, die Pistole hat einen Schalldämpfer und sowas in der Richtung.
Die haben da relativ viel geändert.
Ja, also viele, viele Waffen sind jetzt auch Projektile und nicht mehr, und nicht mehr
normale Hitscan-Waffen, AI ist besser, die haben die Animationen und vor allem haben
sie die Effekte, also Partikeleffekte, Feuereffekte und sowas, haben sie ziemlich verbessert,
wohlgemerkt, wohlgemerkt, das passiert alles immer noch auf der Half-Life 1, also auf
der Gold-Source-Engine, das ist jetzt nix wie Black Mesa, Black Mesa war ja quasi in
aktuellen Source-Engine nachgebautes Half-Life 1. Das ist wirklich Half-Life 1 gemoddet und einfach
Sachen eingebaut, die es noch nicht gegeben hat. Es gibt ein bisschen mehr Content, die Levels sind
minimal an manchen Stellen angepasst und es ist eigentlich, wenn man, also für Leute die Half-Life
schon gespielt haben, ist es nice mal wieder zu spielen. Für neue Leute ist es keine schlechte
Idee damit jetzt anzufangen, wenn sie mal Half-Life spielen wollen. Black Mesa oder M-Mod
als erstes Game. Ganz ehrlich, ich würde sagen M-Mod, weil es ist das originale Spiel, nur ein bisschen verbessert oder ein bisschen modernisiert, ein bisschen erweitert.
Also ich würde auf jeden Fall, bevor ich Black Mesa spiele, Half-Life 1 durchspielen und dann bietet sich M-Mod einfach an, weil es das Gameplay ein bisschen mehr nach 2023 anfühlen lässt.
Gerade, guck mal, ich mein, Leute, man hat sogar Beine jetzt.
Gordon Freeman hat Beine.
Moment.
Man hat sogar Beine jetzt.
Hatte man im Original nicht.
Sie sieht jetzt zwar nicht sonderlich schick aus, aber man hat Beine.
Und man hat sogar eine Crouch-Animation.
In den Beinen.
So, ich mach mal die Musik aus.
Gehen wir mal los.
Ja.
Poggy Legs.
Okay, let's go. Also wir sind stehen geblieben, ähm, okay, okay, ich versuch das mal zu erklären für alle, die Half-Life noch nicht gespielt haben.
Also die Half-Life-Story ist ja immer hochgelobt, aber eigentlich ist die Half-Life-Story äußerst simpel und man muss auch ehrlich sagen, so aus 2023er Standards oder selbst damals,
Die reine Story von Half-Life hat jetzt nicht so viel Wahnsinnssinn ergeben, weil ich glaube, es wurde nie erklärt,
also es wird nirgendswo erklärt, warum Gordon Freeman als MIT-studierter Physik-Doktor auf einmal so geil ist mit der MP5 und als Sniper und sowas.
Und warum er das überhaupt alles überlebt. Gut, überleben tut er es wegen seinem Schutzanzug, aber naja.
Also, die Half-Life-Story ergibt nicht allzu viel Sinn, zumindest
Grundstory von Half-Life ist eigentlich relativ simpel, man arbeitet in einer geheimen Forschungsstation, es gibt ein Experiment, an dem man beteiligt ist, das Experiment geht schief,
deswegen gibt es jetzt Aliens auf, ja, in der ganz normalen Welt und
damit das Ganze nicht rauskommt, ist auch noch die Regierung und das Militär da,
um alle zu beseitigen, die es mitbekommen haben, um das Ganze zu vertuschen. So, das ist die Half-Life-Story. Fertig.
Das war es im Endeffekt.
So, erste Hälfte vom Game
Was ist denn da oben los?
Ah, das sind Überreste vom Flugzeug.
Erste Hälfte vom Game
versucht man aus der kaputten Forschungsstation
zu entkommen, die bei dem Experiment
kaputt gegangen ist und
flüchtet, flüchtet vom Militär
wobei flüchtet gut gesagt ist, man bringt einfach
tausende Leute um, sowohl Aliens
als auch Militärleute und alles
und dann wird man gefangen genommen.
Man wird gefangen genommen und dann wird man
in so eine Schrottpresse reingeworfen
Und aus der Schrottpresse sind wir das letzte Mal geflüchtet, da kommt man hier aus dem Rohr raus, weil man aus der Schrottpresse rauskommt und man bekommt alle Waffen abgenommen, wenn man gefangen genommen wird.
Das heißt wir sind jetzt offiziell quasi so in der zweiten Hälfte des Games. Wir haben nichts, wir haben keine Waffen, wir haben nur nen Brecheisen und sonst nix.
Das heißt, wir müssen uns jetzt erstmal Waffen suchen und gucken, wie das Ganze so weiter geht.
Mehr müsst ihr an der Stelle zu Half-Life nicht wissen.
Wie viel Spielzeit braucht man, um das durchzuspielen?
Also, das Speedrun-Weltrekord liegt, glaube ich, bei, haben wir das letzte Mal angeguckt, glaube ich, 26 Minuten.
Normal-Casual-Playthrough würde ich sagen, brauchst du...
Also, wenn du es wirklich zum ersten Mal spielst und Casual würde ich sagen,
8, 9, 10 Stunden, wenn du dir das auch alles anguckst drum herum, wenn du ein bisschen
schneller bist würde ich sagen so 6, 6 Stunden und wenn du wirklich nur durchrennst ohne
Speedrunner zu sein 3,5.
So, ja und in der zweiten Hälfte muss man sagen dreht Half-Life tatsächlich, oh was
Was ist hier los?
Ey was soll das hier?
Ich muss mal kurz abhauen
Ein
Komm her
Bam! In your face
Und jetzt das allerwichtigste
Neues Feature
Charge Attack
Von M-Mod
Und jetzt neue Splatter Effekte
Wie jetzt?
Kann mich nicht splattern?
Bäm!
Hehehehe
Das war quicksave
Erstmal alles zersplattern
Spielst du eigentlich auch CSGO?
Schon lange, lange
Ich hab lange kein CSGO mehr gespielt
Äh, war das jetzt?
Ich glaub ich glaub
Ich glaub ich muss das ablassen, das Wasser
Ich glaub ich hab's
Ich hab's ich hab's kaputt gemacht
Ja, ich bin ich bin kacknupf
Bye FatTime und ihr müsst wissen Gordon Freeman ist a highly trained professional, wie man gerade gesehen hat
Oh, ich bin zu langsam gewesen, Leute
Alter, kann man nicht mal im Flug sich...
Ich hab gesehen, hier hinten gibt es übrigens ein bisschen Energie
Energie. Da ist das Bomber. Und Leute, ich habe das Spiel glaube ich so oft durchgespielt
wie kein anderes Game. Bestimmt 35 Mal oder so. Aber Half-Life 1 ist bestimmt schon 5,
6, 7 Jahre her, wo ich das Original zum letzten Mal durchgespielt habe. Deswegen habe ich
richtig Bock, das jetzt mal wieder mit Modge durchzuspielen. So, ich glaube das fährt
jetzt hoch hier. Ja, Leiter für Sieg bei Half-Life ist eh so ein Ding. So, man muss
jetzt warten bis das hochgefahren ist und jetzt muss man es drehen und schnell
hochklettern besteht noch hoffnung dass teil 3 kommt ehrlich gesagt nicht glaube
nicht
ich glaube nicht
ich meine hoffnung ja hoffnung gibt es da immer irgendwie aber ich glaube nicht
Also ich glaube nicht, dass wirklich nochmal Half-Life 3 rauskommt.
Alex gespielt?
Nee, ich hab kein F- Das ist aber doch ein bisschen laut, oder?
Das dumme ist, ich kann in OBS die Lautstärke nicht richtig sehen.
Das sackt halt mal massiv.
Ja, ein bisschen leiser müssen wir glaube ich doch noch machen.
Lasst mal kurz was ausprobieren.
Jetzt zu leise
Jetzt ist gut. Jetzt optimal.
Jetzt ist gut.
Windows und Sound Settings.
Das ist echt nicht normal.
2015 meinten die Leute
es kommt bald.
Die haben schon 2000
Wann kam Half-Life 2 raus? Ich glaube 2005 oder so. Da haben die Leute schon gesagt, ja, ja, Episode, äh, äh, oder, äh, 2007 haben die Leute gesagt, ja, ja, Episode, äh, drei und so kommt ja auch bald und kam ja bis heute nicht.
So, der Wachmann, der will mir unbedingt seine Pistole geben.
Yep.
Gift
Wir müssen jetzt warten bis
Wir müssen warten bis der zersplattert wird
Wenn der zersplattert wird kann ich seine Pistole aufheben
Sehr schön
Sterben please
Oh oh, oh das ist schlecht
Huh
Nochmal Glück gehabt
Weil, wer die Dinger nicht kennt
Ich werde mal zeigen was passiert wenn man da reinläuft
Dann kriegt man nämlich den Kopf abgebissen
Und dann
Und
Splattert weg
Die die Viecher halten halt in drei hatten glaube ich vier Schüsse aus ja und das ist jetzt auch neu in diesem Mod gibt
Die gibt viele Waffen die haben jetzt einen also sekundär Schuss Modus gab es ja in Half-Life 1 auch schon bei ganz vielen Waffen
Aber die haben jetzt noch oftmals noch Attachments und sowas
Kann man kann man Schalldämpfer drauf machen an die Pistole
Was es bringt? Ich glaube es ist reine Optik und die Schüsse sind leiser. 1, 2, 3, 4.
Ich glaube es ist reine Optik, es bringt einfach gar nichts.
Außer James-Bonds-Feeling.
Achja und das fand ich auch nice in Half-Life, dass man diese Kakerlaken weg... kaputt treten kann.
Wie gesagt, ich hab das Game so ultra oft, so mega oft durchgespielt, wie ich jünger war. Das ist nicht normal.
Trotzdem, wie gesagt, schon eine Weile her, dass... oh, wow!
Wow, schon eine Weile her, dass ich... 1, 2, 3, 4, dass ich zuletzt gespielt habe.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher, wo das jetzt lang geht.
Oh.
Achtung.
Jetzt war alles zu splattern.
die haben auf jeden fall viel gemacht beim mod das merke ich hier allein schon
allein schon bei den ganzen gore effekten
die das plattern jetzt viel besser als im original natürlich äußerst äußerst
richtig wichtiges feature ich weiß 1 2 3 4
headcrabs headcrabs ey komm mal her
habt ihr gesehen wie ich die im flug erwischt habe
Ach ja, auch ein Half-Life erschreckt einen auch mal ganz gerne mit irgendwelchen Zombie-Viechern,
die um die Ecke spawnen.
Übrigens, es hat absolut keinen Sinn, warum ich die zersplatter.
Das ist die zweite Hälfte, also wir sehen jetzt ja die zweite Hälfte vom Game.
Ah, hier ist zu.
ist auch zu dass das pickt jetzt das pickt jetzt auch so richtig ab vom
pacing geiler satz auf deutsch oder will es sich auch nice dass es vom
pacing so ein bisschen ab pickt
ich bin verwirrt vom wo muss man noch mal lang
erstmal kurz also für das dass ich schon also man muss jetzt hier drüber über
diese ganzen über diese ganzen dinger hier das was weiß ich noch hier bei
Die ganzen Stampfer und sonst was.
Am Anfang kommt jetzt hier so ein bisschen
Minimales, so wie soll man sagen
Survival-Kram mit
Zu wenig Munition und
Nahkampf bei den Gegnern.
Ich glaub ich muss wieder zurück zum Start, oder?
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ich muss wieder zurück zum Start, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab.
Ja.
Genau.
schlagen.
Nice.
Und jetzt kommt das, was, glaube ich, niemand in Half-Life 1 wirklich mochte.
Parkour, Parkour-Einlagen.
Siehste, da passieren dann so Sachen wie hier, dass man in die Suppe fällt.
Macht zum Glück alles nicht sonderlich viel Damage.
Also es ist sicherlich nicht alles nice an Half-Life 1, ich muss sagen.
Das haben sie in Black Mesa verbessert, sodass die Sprungeinlagen und so nicht mal ganz so
nervig sind, aber nichtsdestotrotz, ich mochte das Gesamtpaket von Half-Life, weil das war
das erste Game, das war das erste Game, so was ich gespielt habe, wo ich sagen muss,
das hatte halt so eine Zusammen-, also was Shooter angeht, das hatte so eine zusammenhängende
Welt.
Du bist quasi von Anfang bis Ende durchgelaufen, ohne dass jetzt großartig Levelgrenzen in dem Sinn zu sehen gab.
Und die Welt an sich ist stimmig und die Abwechslung war halt auch nice.
Ja, erst aus der Forschungsstation raus, dann wird das unterbrochen durch so'n mini-Survival-Path.
Danach gibt's richtig, richtig krass, am Ende kommst du halt in so'ne Alien-Welt, also ist schon...
Also Half-Life war nicht umsonst wegweisend.
Übrigens, ich weiß, dass das hier jetzt einbricht.
Oh shit, jetzt hab ich's verkackt. Ich lade nochmal schnell.
Eigentlich sollte das hier einbrechen.
Macht's nicht. Okay, 1, 2, 3, 4.
Warum bricht das nicht ein?
Ich bin mir eigentlich relativ sicher gewesen, dass das hier einbricht.
Oh, das kommt jetzt bestimmt noch, oder?
Hä? War das so eine reine Black Mesa-Geschichte, dass das einbricht?
Ich hätte wetten können, das hier ist auch eingebrochen.
Weil die haben doch nicht umsonst hier unten diesen ganzen Kram hingemacht.
Guck mal, die Aliens sind auch ziemlich pipega.
Oh.
Ach da kann man unten drunter durch.
Gibt es hier Munition? Ah nice!
Okay dann war das im Original
gar nicht so, dass die
Rohre eingebrochen sind.
Zimmer.
Ich hätte wetten können, die Rohre
sind eingebrochen, ja.
Oder vielleicht hier?
Moment, wenn man, wenn man zu... Alter! Game!
Das... Alter!
Also die Steuerung ist teilweise...
Ich komm hier nicht weiter, ich bleib an der...
Ah, hier ist die Röhre eingebrochen, ok.
Ich hab schon pro-proactive agile mitgedacht, dass die Röhre da vorne einbricht.
Hast du schon mal die Half-Life Speedruns gesehen?
Ja, hab ich. Wir haben uns das letzte Mal nach dem Stream, haben uns den aktuellen Weltrekord angeguckt.
Extrem krasser Scheiß, ey.
Also, ich bin der Parkour-King, was Half-Life angeht.
Ja, wir haben uns das letzte Mal angeguckt. Das ist extrem krass gewesen, ey.
Vor allem, wie precise...
Könnt ihr euch noch an den Speedrun erinnern?
Wo da hier diese Parcours durchgerannt ist?
Jetzt kommt, glaube ich, das mit den Förderbändern, oder?
Kommt das mit den Förderbändern?
Ah, ja, genau!
Aber erstmal alles, erstmal alles... Oh, was ist hier los?
Äh, ich bin stuck.
Dead.
Wo ist das Viech?
Gucken, ob irgendwas drin ist.
Munition und Schild kann man immer gebrauchen.
Guck mal, das war Stuck, die Headcrab.
Ich frage mich, ja, und das habe ich mich schon, als ich Half-Life 1 gespielt habe, gefragt.
Ähm, NacroTV, danke schön für den Sub, das habe ich schon bei Half-Life 1 gefragt,
ist, was soll das hier?
Was soll das hier, oh geil, was soll das hier eigentlich sein?
Also ich meine, irgendeine Müllpresse oder Müllbeförderungs-Dings-Anlage oder was ist das eigentlich?
Ey, meine Güte.
Ja schön, dass du deinen Weg hergefunden hast.
Also keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Eine Müllbeförderungs-Müllverbrennungs-Müllpressanlage, wo aber irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen überall Körperteile rauskommen?
Hä?
Und... Charge! Bäm!
Next! Bäm!
Jawoll!
Biogasanlage!
Ich glaub, da haben die da noch nicht dran gedacht.
Ach, jetzt kommt dieser Unter...
Ah, jetzt kommt dieser Part, wo man tauchen muss und durch diese...
an den Walzen vorbei.
Ey, gehst du weg, Headcrab?
Glück hab ich genug Schuss.
So eine Art Kläranlage aus Amerika.
Das könnte natürlich sein, wobei man sich fragt, warum klären die da
Körperteile?
Gut, bei den Amis weiß man ja nie.
Ging es hier lang? Ich glaube, hier ging es lang.
Jetzt ist er weg. Oh, hinter mir ist noch eins! Shit!
Oh oh shit!
Ich habe schon überhaupt kein Leben mehr richtig. Jetzt müssen wir aber aufpassen.
Ah gut, huh, Glück gehabt!
Ich habe das halb aufgeladen in den Auto geschossen.
Das ist ein halb aufgeladener Automat.
Okay, das haben die in dem Mod geändert.
Also es gab im Original schon viele Headcrabs, aber nicht so viele.
What?
Hat mich bitte schon jetzt gerade gekillt?
Die Tür? Hat mich die Tür... Moment das muss ich nochmal ausdrehen. Mich hat die Tür
gekillt und... Geil! Ich glaub die Tür ist ein bisschen verbuggt. Wenn man zu nah an
Tür steht, bringt einen die Tür um.
Okay, wir gehen mal, wir gehen mal
vorsichtig, vorsichtig.
Moment, wir sind wieder am...
Wait a minute, sind wir wieder am Anfang?
Okay, dann mussten
wir hier auf jeden Fall nicht hin, weil wir wieder am Anfang
sind.
Dann waren wir, waren wir hier falsch.
Gab's hier hinten noch
irgendwas?
Ich glaub, dann müssen wir weiter tauchen.
Ja, ja, ja, wir müssen weiter tauchen.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Okay, hier können wir nicht auftauchen.
Ah, jetzt sind wir durch. Genau.
Oh, Stampf- Stampfsohr.
Woah, woah, woah, au, au, au.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, ich bin mir nicht sicher, wo die Viecher sind.
Alter, hier sitzt der überall, Headcrabs.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie kriegen wir das gebacken.
Ich sag ja mal richtig krasse, okay, wie machen wir das?
Vielleicht soll ich nicht so viel
Ich weiß wie wir das machen, das Vieh sieht mich unter Wasser nicht, oder?
Pepega Vieh
Etke
Nice
Gekletscht
Granaten? Gab's die nicht?
Ah, nice
Minen
Und
Der Revolver
Pogu
Leute, jemand Bock auf eine Runde pixelliche Pizza?
Jetzt mal
Ich mein, man kann wenig erkennen
Weil, es ist pixel
Aber was würdet ihr sagen, was das ist?
Ich würd sagen, das sieht tatsächlich bisschen nach Oliven auf der Pizza aus
Und man kann es nicht... Oh.
Hat ein bisschen was von Oliven.
So, erstmal die Dampfer anhalten.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ach der... Hä?
What the fuck?
Okay, wir müssen echt aufpassen, ganz schön viel Damage.
Hier gehe ich nicht mehr, nein, nein, nein, die Tür benutze ich nicht mehr, nach der
letzten Tür, die mich fast gekillt hat.
Oliven, rote Zwiebeln, Basilikum, Gemfire Axe, Oliven, ich mag Oliven, Pizza.
Wir brauchen einen exzellenten Six-Head-Half-Life-Physics-Knowledge-Dude.
Wie komme ich hier oben drauf?
Ich brauche irgendeine Kiste.
Irgendeine Kiste, wo gibt es eine Kiste?
Leute, wisst ihr, was meine Lieblingspizza ist?
Es kommt jetzt ein bisschen random bei den ganzen Innereien, die wir hier sehen, aber
3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23, 24, 25, 26,
27, 28, 29, 30, 31, 32, 33, 34, 35, 36, 37, 38, 39, 40, 40, 41, 42, 42, 43, 44,
44, 45, 46, 47, 48, 49, 50, 51, 52, 52, 53, 54, 55, 56, 57, 57, 58, 59, 60, 60,
Rekt. Kein Ananas, nee, Sardellen.
Und Soos Hollandaise. Ohne Mist, Soos Hollandaise Pizza ist auch mega. Hähnchen, Hähnchen
und Soos Hollandaise Pizza. Das hab ich auch immer gern gegessen, als es noch bei uns beim
Lieferservice gab. Natürlich wird der Purist jetzt sagen, das ist aber nichts, was man
auf seine Pizza machen sollte. Da kann ich nur sagen, soll doch das auf die Pizza machen,
was einem schmeckt. Äh, ich bin mega pippiger. Ne, das kann überhaupt nicht funktionieren,
so Sekunde, ich bin, ich bin zu blöd gewesen. Wartet mal. So, jetzt. Alter, ich bin zu dumm
für die Steuerung, man.
Okay, nice, geschafft.
Ne, aber Hähnchensauce-Hollandaise-Pizza
ist extremely
pog.
Ah, jetzt kommt das mit den
Minen. Moment, Headcrab?
Jebaited, die muss jebaited werden, die Headcrab.
Headcrab, jebaiten.
Jebaited. Na gut, dann halt nicht.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Das haben die neu gemacht, das war glaube ich im Original nicht so, warte mal.
Shit, wir haben keine Munition mehr.
Ähm...
Moment, wollen wir mal gucken.
Kann man hier oben drauf?
Shit.
Okay, ich hoffe...
Oh.
Ja, ja, knapp.
Shit!
Okay, das da hinten müssen wir irgendwie killen, das Viech.
Ja, down.
Okay.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Da hatte ich aber Glück.
Mal ein K.S.
Stampf-Saw.
Warum auch immer hier Stampfer sind.
Leute, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, dann konnte man hier jetzt ein bisschen
klitschen.
Und zwar, ich glaube man konnte, wenn man es richtig gemacht hat, den hier killen und
dann hier durchhoppen.
Ne, aber es geht auch so.
Aber hier kommt man nicht durch.
Ich hab ne Idee. Ich hab ne Idee. Achtung. So.
Auf. Alter, wenn man die Controls nicht kennt, ist halt pp gar.
What?
Wie jetzt?
Wollt ihr mich ver...
Game.
Weird Champ.
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Guckt euch das mal an.
Warum geht das nicht kaputt?
Okay, jetzt ist es kaputt.
Die Effekte sind auch richtig cool gemacht.
Im Vergleich zu den originalen Half-Life-1-Effekten.
Jetzt konnte man hier durchhoppen,
weil das war, glaube ich, soweit ich weiß,
nicht gedacht
vom
vom Hersteller, dass man hier durchhoppen kann.
Aber wir machen das jetzt.
Pie-Fat-Time
Pipo-Fat
Oh nice
Ok, das haben sie cool designt
Dass man rückwärts läuft
von dem Zombie, meint ihr das ist Absicht?
Ich glaube das ist Absicht
Dass man rückwärts läuft von dem Zombie und dann rückwärts in die Shotgun läuft, das ist bestimmt Absicht.
Wenn es Absicht ist, dann ist es extrem pfeifett gemacht.
Weil's geht.
Die Soundeffekte sind beste, ja.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob wir nicht einfach hier weiter hoppen sollten.
Das ist das das ist nicht der intendent way der intendent way ist der hier
Was zum
So ganz what the hell was das
Warum trifft das nicht bin genau drauf
Leute, ich muss noch eine kleine Extra-Runde machen, ich habe ein bisschen wenig Leben.
Wobei, wenn wir das Ding treffen, wir sollten, warte mal, wir machen das von hier.
Wir haben doch, wir haben doch irgendwo hier sogar so ein Sniper, das ist doch jetzt in
dem Mod neu, Sniper-Mode für die, für den Revolver.
Ja, so ist gut.
Six-Head-Mode.
Six Head Mode
So und hier können wir jetzt die Handgranaten benutzen
Oh Oh Alter
Achtung jetzt
Bäm Jawoll Nice
Jetzt haben wir es geschafft
Jetzt geht es hier raus
Ich renne heute ja wirklich echt
wirklich echt überall rein wo man nur rein rennen kann krieg ich der oh hier unten kriegt man damage
das ist dreck wasser hier bekommt man damage das ist ziemlich dumm dass man hier damage bekommt
Was?
Ey von...
What the f...
Ey von was kriege ich Damage?
Man weiß es nicht so genau
Highly trained professional
So siehts aus
Was ist das denn?
Das ist ein...
Ein...
Müllpresse?
Oder...
Irgendjemand hat doch gesagt, das ist eine
Ami-Kläranlage, oder?
Habt ihr eine sinnvolle Erklärung
für eine...
für sowas in einer Kläranlage?
Vielleicht bin ich einfach nur blöd
und jede Kläranlage hat sowas.
Re...
Was ist das für ein Ding?
Ey, wie zum Teufel soll ich denn das hier alles überleben?
Kann man da irgendwie...
Ah, ok.
Hier kann man so eine Zwischenlandung machen.
Weil ansonsten...
Leute, wir haben ein kleines...
Wir haben ein kleines...
Leute wir haben ein kleines, wir haben ein kleines Problem. Ich muss hier irgendwie ohne Munition durchkommen.
Haben wir vielleicht hier irgendwo so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen Muni? Ich hab, ich hab genau einen Schuss noch in der Pistole.
Nice.
Nice, sehr gut. Läuft, läuft bei uns. Läuft richtig gut.
Pass mal auf, der Witchy baited.
Ja, ich habe ihn an...
Outplayed Headcrab.
Das dumme ist nur, dass hier keine Munition liegt.
Kann ich das...
Oh, oh, oh, shit! Wir sind dead. Oder nicht?
Wir sind dead, aber, passt mal auf, wir machen jetzt Five-Head-Time.
Wir laden eine Granate auf, werfen die Granate rein und gehen wieder runter.
Und bam, jetzt sollte hoffentlich alles tot sein. Ne, nicht.
Okay. Alles dead. So muss das sein. Pork. Wir haben aber selbst. Okay, wir haben keine
Munition, Leute. Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, wie man das hier macht ohne Munition. Kann
man über das Dach irgendwie? Normalerweise muss man glaube ich diesen... das Ding anballern
da hinten. Vielleicht kann man es auch irgendwie jumpen. Wir haben ja keine Munition. Kann
kann man das irgendwie...
Shit!
Nein, nein, nein, das ist voll...
In der Situation war
ich noch nie.
Okay.
Woah!
Doch, mein Revolver ist leer.
Ach ne, ist nicht leer.
Ich dachte irgendwie, der ist leer.
Okay, mal kurz leben.
Nice, wieder 30%.
Okay, ein Schuss hätte gereicht. Ich hätt's mir sparen können, das rumgestellte.
Aber okay. Das war wirklich Klaus. Fünf Leben noch.
Wir müssen uns jetzt mal ein bisschen zusammenraffen hier.
Ah, nächstes Kapitel. Nice, Suho.
Und ich bin dumm, wir haben jetzt sogar noch ne Shotgun.
Die hab ich ja ganz vergessen. Easy, die brauchen wir jetzt auch.
Ich hab, als ich das erste Mal das Game gespielt hab, oder die ersten Mal,
Ich hab immer versucht, ob man dieses Ding hier nicht irgendwie aufbekommt, aber ne...
Das ist neu.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, das ging im Original nicht.
Guck mal, kann dem den Fuß schießen.
Der hat ge... Das ist natürlich sinnlose Munitionverschwendung, das machen wir nicht.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das im Original... Das ging wirklich?
Das ist mir neu. Siehste mal, man lernt nicht aus.
Oh shit! Das war doch... Das... Näääh, im Leben war das doch im Original nicht so.
war das wirklich so?
dass man dieses, dass das Viech dann herausgekommen ist?
ok, vielleicht, vielleicht das ist einfach zu lange her
wo ich das Original gespielt habe
aber
ich, ich bilde mir einmal, konnte das nicht
konnte das nicht killen
Leute, wir haben kaum noch Leben, Alter
Highly trained professional
Professional ist unterwegs
Wir kriegen auch die mienen sehr schön
Ich bräuchte ich bräuchte mal ein bisschen schild und ein bisschen leben
Moin was geht
Sorry du kannst nix für aber ich brauche munition
Sehr schön jetzt erstmal alle headcrabs zerstören
Ja, vielleicht ist es wirklich zu lange her, dass ich das Original gespielt habe.
Die letzten Male habe ich nur Black Mesa gespielt.
Black Mesa habe ich auch so 4-5 mal durchgespielt insgesamt.
Und vielleicht bringe ich es einfach durcheinander gerade.
Ist ja möglich.
Wow!
Ich muss noch mal laden, ich bin dead, ich habe zu wenig Leben.
So, wir müssen den Typen jetzt one-shotten, wenn er um die Ecke kommt.
Oder, wenn wir Glück haben und er ist gespawnt, können wir ihn wallbangen mit einer Granate.
Hehehehehehe, predicted!
In welchem Chapter befindest du dich?
Äh, das ist questionable ethics, heißt das glaube ich, das Chapter.
Also, ich krieg die, achso hier, guck mal, äh, tatsächlich, guck mal.
Ich weiß sogar aus dem Kopf, wie die Chapter heißen.
Questionable Ethics, steht nicht da.
Jawoll, MP5, easy win.
Das ist jetzt übrigens auch neu in dem Mod, im originalen Half-Life hat die MP5 ja den
normalen, also ich zeig das mal kurz, du hast den normalen Feuermodus, du hast, ach ich
hab keine Granaten, Rechtsklick ist ein Granatwerfer und jetzt mit dem Mod kannst du noch Stelzmode,
den Stelzmode aktivieren.
Dann hört sich das Gesilencede an.
Meine persönliche Vermutung ist, ich hab's Damagetechnik nicht ausprobiert, aber meine
Vermutung ist, der Damage zwischen Silencer und nicht Silencer ist exakt das gleiche.
Ex...
op
Aha, jetzt probieren wir mal aus, ob wir die Typen
Baten können
Seid ihr blind oder was ich bin hier
Horgas AI
Ich will euch jetzt
Geil gemacht, Max! Sehr schlau! Sehr schlau!
Jetzt aber! Bam! Jawoll! Das ist eigentlich das, was ich die ganze Zeit schon machen wollte!
Ich wollte die reinlocken, die Granate!
So, jetzt haben wir nahezu unendlich Muni, dadurch dass Soldaten hier am Start...
Oh, shit.
Pass mal auf, Sniper-Mode aktiviert.
Get rekt.
Outmoved.
Outmoved, outgunned, outplayed.
Outgunned, Outplayed, hier die Leute.
So, hier kommen wir nicht raus.
Ich glaube das ist die Lobby,
wo wir dann zum Schluss raus müssen.
Hallo Barney, was ist so los hier?
Oh, siehst nicht gut aus, Barney.
Oh, Barney sieht gar nicht gut aus.
Sieht ziemlich fertig aus.
Ich glaube,
übrigens, dass es
von der Half-Life-Lore her so ist,
dass der allererste Wachmann,
den man im Tunnel sieht, noch in der Train-Sequenz, dass das lore-technisch offiziell Barney sein soll.
Also, den man im Intro sieht. Alle anderen sehen zwar genauso aus, aber das ist nicht Barney.
Barney ist nur der Erste. Aber gut, Half-Life-Lore und Half-Life-Story,
nach all den Jahren wahrscheinlich gibt es alles nicht so viel Sinn.
Ach, jetzt gibt's die Viecher. Wer soll Barney sein? Der Wachmann.
Äh, äh, äh, äh. Das ist auch im Original nicht so. Das ist definitiv, Leute. Das ist garantiert im Original nicht so.
Aber tausendprozentig ist das im Original nicht so.
Also wer mir sagt, dass das im Original so ist, der hat das Original nie gespielt.
Oder ihr wollt mich einfach nur ganz krass gibaden.
Also falls ihr es gerade nicht mitgekriegt habt, das Alien hat den Knopf gedrückt für den Versuch.
Hier, so wie ich das auch machen kann.
Das das war im original nicht so dass das fiech gab es hier nicht
Ich glaube man konnte selbst im original draufdrücken hat konnte so ein paar fiecher in die luft sprengen
Aber so rum gab war das auf jeden fall nicht
Jetzt gibt es gleich die
Eigentlich, man könnte sagen die unbeliebteste Waffe in ganz Half-Life.
Es gibt so komische...
Explodier...
und...
ja...
Beiß- und Explodier-
Aliens.
Die kann man, guck hier so funktioniert das.
Die kann man auf die Gegner werfen.
Und die gehen dann auf die Gegner und machen die Gegner kaputt.
Wenn sie nicht rumbacken.
Das Problem ist nur,
wenn die Gegner down sind,
Ich zeige euch das mal und man geht da hin, dann gehen sie, dann gehen sie auf einen selbst, ja?
Deswegen muss man immer ganz weit weg stehen, warten bis die Viecher, bis die Viecher tot sind.
Guck, guck, genau das meine ich.
Und dann explodieren sie in einer Zeit.
So, wir nehmen mal die Shotgun.
Kann man?
Okay, okay, pass mal auf.
Ich hoffe man kann.
Komm um die Ecke, komm um die Ecke.
Komm um die Ecke.
Ja egal, so gehts auch.
Die Explosionen sehen viel besser aus,
wie noch mit Original Half-Life.
Und auch die, auch die Feuereffekte.
Effekte. Alter, was ne Sauerei. Wo geht's hier lang? Ah, da kommen wir gerade. Da kommen
wir doch gerade her, oder? Ja, ja, hier kommen wir her. 1, 2, 3, 4. 1, 2, 3, 4. So, wir
Wir snipen jetzt mal welche mit dem crossbow, bin mal gespannt, haben die, ne es gibt keinen dritten feuermodus für den crossbow
Leute ist
Ist der pfeil nicht falsch herum auf dem
Crossbow, die spitze, ach ne das, okay doch nicht, die spitze ist vorne, das sollen so eine art federn von dem pfeil sein
Achtung, Achtung, Schneider, Massive Schneider, nix da, ok, Stelzmodus, ich hör da was laufen.
Ich bin begeistert, wie gut man einfach die Gegner hört.
Man hat ihn halt einfach drei Kilometer schon gehört und das im Jahr 2023.
Also ich hätte das nicht nach Call of Duty Vanguard und MW1 nicht für möglich gehalten,
dass man noch 2023 Games spielen kann, die Fußschritte von Gegnern ortbar haben.
Wir müssen jetzt mal hier durch, wir müssen mal kurz hier durchstelzen.
Ja, die haben mich noch nicht bemerkt.
Ach komm, ein Treffer noch. Bam.
Die haben mich noch nicht bemerkt. Ich will die snipen.
Oh, noch besser.
Ich will euch snipen. Ihr seid doch hier oben, oder?
Lul. Was? Was? Ne Munitionsverschwendung.
Für ne Headcrab, nen Pfeil.
Fall
Kann es sein dass hier noch gar keine soldaten sind erst wenn man ja ich glaube ich glaube man muss erst die dinger in die luft bringen
Ja
Schräg. Die sterben nicht mehr. Habe ich die gerade wallbanged?
Oder nicht wallbanged, collateral damaged?
Okay Viech, du willst bestimmt hier.
Ey, ich bin hier oben, komm mal hoch.
Ihr dürft euch gerne gegenseitig killen, da habe ich kein Problem mit.
Aber du willst, du willst hier lang. Nee, nee, fiech, fiech. Du willst hier lang. Auf jeden Fall. Du willst unbedingt hier lang.
Hier, hier lang. Komm mal her.
Komm her. Komm her. Ja, komm. Mensch.
Okay, das hat keinen Bock. Das ist gebuggt.
Dead.
Ja, haben wir leider so eine Mine verschenkt.
Wow!
Wie... Das ist jetzt neues, oder?
Dead.
Nice.
Kann man die Dinger wieder einsammeln?
Leider nicht.
Ich... Weiß jemand, ob man die Dinger in
Plank Mesa einsammeln konnte, wieder?
Die Minen, bin mir nicht sicher. Wäre auf jeden Fall ein sehr sinnvolles Feature.
Ah, noch mehr Minen.
Explosive Kisten.
Beste, wenn sie in ihre eigenen Minen rennen, exzellent.
Äußerst sinnvoll hier Kisten hinzustellen, aber das ist man ja gewohnt in Half-Life,
an vielen Stellen einfach random Kisten stehen, die keinen Sinn machen.
Wow, der hat sich nicht headshotten lassen.
Ah, fast.
Ah, jetzt kommt dieses Ding.
Da habe ich mich auch gefragt,
wo ich noch ein bisschen kleiner war und das Game gespielt habe,
welchen Sinn hat dieser Raum?
Ein Raum mit so einem rumfahrenden, gefährlichen Ding.
Also warum, was ist, warum baut man diesen Raum?
Erstmal eine Runde Headcrabs entsorgen, Headcrabs entsorgen, noch mehr Headcrabs entsorgen und
Zombies entsorgen
Komm her!
Bäm!
Und ganz wichtig
Erstmal splattern
Ja in Black Mesa ist es ein
Operationsroboter
Warum splatterst du nicht?
Aha
Beste
Jeder ernsthafte Wissenschaftler hat so einen Raum um die eigene
Dafür würde er sogar Sinn machen, ja.
Okay, da kommen wir her.
Wow.
Oh, shit!
What the hell?
Wo kommt denn das Zeug her?
Jetzt bräuchten wir...
Wir bräuchten den Dead Space Flammenwerfer.
What the?
Das Mini-Headcrabs
Die sieht man ja überhaupt nicht, okay
Die kann man aber bestimmt mit der
Komm her
Genau
Einfach zerquetschen mit der Brechstange
Ja guck mal, da sind noch mehr
Eins, zwei, drei
Das sind Mini-Shelobs!
Guck mal!
Nee, Moment, Shelob war die aus Herr der Ringe, oder?
Sorry, sorry, ich bin... Nee, nee, nee, nee!
Ähm...
Shelob ist die Spinne aus
Herr der Ringe. Wie hieß das Viech?
Gonarch, Gonarchslerk.
Wir sind ja in Half-Life!
Ja gut.
Kann man sich schon mal vertun.
Hier müssen wir später lang.
Ich lass die Dinger extra da, damit ich mir das merken kann,
dass wir hier noch nicht gewesen sind.
Gonarch hieß das Ding in Half-Life.
Das Spinnenviech.
Was dann, was später...
Oh, Sekunde.
Ich werde mal die Viecher platt machen, weil ich glaube die Soldaten sind nicht so das Problem gerade.
Hey, kannst du mich mal in Ruhe lassen?
Was ist das hier?
Nice Aim!
Vielleicht habe ich Glück und die sind so doof und checken es nicht, dass ich auf sie schieße gerade.
Es sieht danach aus, als kapieren sie es nicht.
Guck mal.
Die kapieren es nicht.
Pepega Marines.
Jetzt kommt der Kram mit dem Laser.
Ich erinnere mich.
Aber wenn man jetzt hier um die Ecke läuft, links rum, da kommen jetzt die Typen, die sich selbst mit einer Waffe in die Luft sprengen.
Ja.
Hier, pass auf.
Das ist eines der geilsten Waffen im Game.
Ist auch die Beste um Helis zu killen und sowas.
Oh, alles dead.
Also ich muss ja sagen, die KI, also die verbessert wurde.
Vielleicht, vielleicht ist es ja auch normal, dass wenn man beschossen wird, dass man stehen
bleibt.
Aber ich muss sagen, die von der verbesserten KI, sag mal, die KI ist doch nicht verbessert
Leute.
Hi.
Geiler Dude.
Okay, es kann, Leute, es kann durchaus sein, dass die KI im Original auch so pepega war.
Man war damals extrem beeindruckt.
Wisst ihr noch, falls jemals so 1998 in Trirum dabei war, wisst ihr noch von welchem anderen Game man sowohl grafisch als auch KI-technisch damals übelst beeindruckt gewesen ist, neben Half-Life, kam ungefähr zu gleichem Zeitraum, ich glaub ein Jahr früher.
Hat übrigens keinen Sinn, dass ich da jetzt drauf kloppe gerade.
System Shock.
Ey, ja nee, nicht wirklich.
Von Unreal.
Also Unreal Grafik, allerdings die KI war damals auch extrem nice.
Also Unreal wurde auch ziemlich für die KI abgefeiert.
Allerdings war die Half-Life-KI damals noch ein Tick besser.
Man hat es jetzt dazu wirklich erkannt, ehrlich gesagt.
Die KI macht auch ziemliche Aussetzer gerade.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Bug im Mod ist oder ob die KI wirklich so blöd gewesen ist im Original.
Also die Half-Life 2 KI ist auf jeden Fall oder AI für die Soldaten ist auf jeden Fall deutlich cleverer als das hier gerade.
Ähm, hab ich jetzt eigentlich alles? War's das? Ich glaub ich hab alles, ja.
So, jetzt erstmal ein Loch in die Wand brennen.
Ah, ne, Moment!
Moment, ich hab was, siehste, Pepega-Time.
Wie gesagt, 35 Mal gespielt mindestens, aber das weiß ich natürlich nicht mehr.
Man muss die Kiste hier, das war quasi eines der ersten Physik-Rätsel, was sie dann in
Half-Life 2 auf die Spitze getrieben haben.
Kann man das überhaupt Physikrätsel nennen? Nicht wirklich, oder?
Er ist so... Umgebungsrätsel.
Ist ja nicht wirklich ein Physikrätsel. Ist ja alles gescriptet.
So eine richtig...
So eine richtig gescheite Physik-Engine hat das Game ja nicht.
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Seht ihr, wie die Kiste rumspackt?
Und wie kacke ich...
Wie ich mich nicht bewegen kann, wenn ich die Kiste schiebe und sowas.
Also für SIG-Engine hat das Game keine wirklich...
...durchdachte.
Aber ey, das ist jetzt von 1998.
Und man kann es ja auch irgendwie übertreiben mit den Ansprüchen.
Oh. Übrigens, System Shock
gab's letztens in Remake. Habt ihr das gespielt?
Oder hat sich das jemand, jemand, äh,
schon angeschaut? Ich hab's mir gekauft
Und bin so die ersten paar Räume lang. Und ich muss sagen, atmosphärisch ist das extrem nice.
Ich hab nie ausprobiert, was passiert, wenn die Wissenschaftler sterben von diesem Ding.
Okay. Oder was pa-
ach man kann tatsächlich an der stelle game over gehen gibt es neuere unreal
spiele es gibt unreal 1 unreal 2 unreal tournament 2004 und das das neue unreal
tournament hatten sie ja die entwicklung eingestellt weil sie jetzt fortnite
haben. Und Fortnite einfach viel geiler ist. Für die, was Money verdienen angeht, als
Unreal wahrscheinlich je gewesen ist. Ja auf, ne ne, du wählst es nicht vor deinen
Colleagues, du kommst jetzt mit. Mitkommen? Du auch mitkommen. Ja, auf Leute, hopp hopp,
Move!
Moved euch!
Ach gut, da kommst halt nur du mit, das ist mir auch egal, hauptsache einer kommt mit.
Einer kommt mit und jetzt müssen wir, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, wir müssen wieder runter.
Irgendwie, wo ging's runter?
Nein!
What the f...
Warum ist da grad was explod...
Der ist vorne weggerannt und ist gestorben.
So, komm mit.
Ja, ja, komm mit, komm mit, komm mit.
Ne, jetzt rennt er nicht vorne weg.
So.
So, weil ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt in den Gang zurück.
Oh shit, alter, ne.
Fuck, wo muss man...
Ne, hier raus können wir doch jetzt, oder?
Ja, da, mach auf!
Ja, CU.
zu
Ich fasse es nicht leute ich bin ich bin gekletscht in der tür
Doch war
Okay, Achtung.
Ja, der Mod ist noch nicht so ganz bugfrei.
Wir müssen mal gucken, hier sind jetzt...
Hier sind jetzt Sentry Guns draußen.
Ah, hier, doch, hier sind Sentry Guns, ne?
Kann man, kann man hier rüber?
Kann man hier irgendwie... Guck mal hier kann man oben langlaufen, glaube irgendwie.
Wir müssen mal kurz die Sentry Gun ausschalten da oben.
Was?
So.
Alter, der hält aber ganz gut was aus hier.
Oh, noch ne Sentry Gun, shit!
Der hat ge...
Nein, doch nicht, der hat ge...
Jetzt aber.
Wie kommt man hier rüber?
Ich hätte jetzt ja mal gesagt...
Ups, jetzt habe ich raus getappt.
Ich kann...
Ich würde ja sagen, irgendwie hier ist hier so.
Aber das scheint ja so nicht zu klappen.
Ne.
Kommt man hier irgendwie rauf?
Irgendwo...
Irgendwo da?
Weil es ist eindeutig gedacht, dass man hier irgendwie raufkommt.
Wenn es nämlich nicht gedacht wäre, dass man hier raufkommt, dann
würde auf der Seite kein Revolver liegen.
Kennst du auch zufällig bei älteren Spielen?
Ich bin 1984 geboren, ich kenne jede Menge ältere Spiele.
Muss man vielleicht irgendwie Anlauf nehmen, oder hat einer
Hat eine schlaue Idee, wie man hier hochkommt.
Ne, so nicht.
Ist auch egal, ich mein, es ist jetzt nicht so, als bräuchten wir das unbedingt.
Oh!
In your face!
Vielleicht den Zaun zerstören?
Das sieht nicht so aus wie eine... wie was, was man zerstören könnte.
Gravity... wie bräuchte ich jetzt die Gravity Gun?
Bestimmt Bait. Ja, wahrscheinlich ist es echt Bait.
Debated.
Die haben glaube ich auch die Crossbow-Ammo ein bisschen runtergeschraubt.
Ich bilde mir ein, im Original hatte man mehr Crossbow-Ammo.
Achtung, Achtung, jetzt wird er langsam.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Achtung, ich weiß, dass die Gegner sind.
Ja, damit habt ihr nicht gerechnet, ha?
Da hat sich das MIT-Studium richtig gelohnt.
Ich meine, es gab irgendwo einen Tunnel hinter den Stromkästen, okay.
Ja, aber jetzt sind wir schon im anderen Level, hier wird das nirgendswo mehr sein.
Heli stellts!
Ich bin mir nicht mehr sicher, ob wir den Heli hier jetzt killen mussten auf der Map
oder ob das erst später kommt.
Doch, ich glaube wir können den Heli hier killen.
Easy.
Alles, das ist die geilste Waffe, ich, das ist meine absolute Lieblingswaffe in Half-Life.
Wie heißt das Ding, Gauss Cannon, oder?
Das ist Pog. Einfach aufgeladen, alles in die Luft gesprengt. Easy.
Okay, ja.
Genauso hätte ich das auch gebaut hier.
Also, so ganz fehlerfrei ist der Mod nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die Fische normalerweise so an der Oberfläche geschwommen sind,
dass man sie, dass man sie killen kann.
Ähm, jetzt müssen wir hier... Oh, ich hasse sowas, ey.
Ihr kennt mich, ne? Ihr wisst, dass ich tiefe, trübe, unbekannte Gewässer und so halt überhaupt nicht mag.
Also auch Reallife. Ich kann halt auch nicht im See richtig schwimmen gehen, ohne dass ich ein blödes Gefühl hab.
Okay, wir müssen...
Ja, ist ja gut, man!
Okay, wir haben zwei Schuss mit dem Bogen, um das Viech zu killen.
Wo bist du?
Eins.
Fuck. Komm her.
Zwei.
Wie, das lebt noch?
Shit.
So funktioniert das schon mal nicht.
Okay, wir müssen uns beeilen.
Wir tauchen jetzt einfach durch.
Wir können nicht durchtauchen
Ah guck mal das ist PP gar das fieste
Das ist verbuggt
Kecke
Ha!
Sehr schön!
Er sieht etwas geschockt aus!
Kann man das Viech splattern?
Ich glaube das geht nicht, ich glaube das kann man nicht kaputt machen.
Es sieht...
Ach ja, jetzt...
Jetzt ist auf einmal
Okay, so kann man es auch machen
Wenn man zu blöd ist das game zu spielen kann man einfach die gegner klitschen
Half-Life trauma ja ist echt ein bisschen so
Ja
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
Muss nochmal kurz auftauchen
Gordon, schwimm mal ein bisschen schneller
Luft holen
Luft holen, ja, ja, ja, gut, gut
Weiter, weiter Luft holen
Okay, genug Luft geholt
Andere Seite ist es.
Hab ich, hab ich? Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich hab was vergessen.
Ich hab was vergessen. Ich glaub,
ich glaub man muss den Motor noch anmachen, dass das funktioniert.
Habe ich den Motor noch nicht angemacht?
Ist es verbuggt?
Fragezeichen
Ist es, ist es verbuggt?
Oder muss ich noch irgendwie Strom einschalten?
Oder sowas?
Oh, das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht
Ich meine, ich komme ja nicht mehr raus.
Gab's hier... Moment, musste ich hier irgendwas noch machen, was ich nicht mehr weiß?
Ich glaube da kann man nicht durchtauchen so oder ich bin oder ich bin zu blöd und
ich muss es einfach mal probieren durchzutauchen es kann ja auch sein dass es einfach nur so
aussehen als kann man nicht durch ich meine das game ist 20 jahre alt
äh nee 25 jahre alt
okay ich hab nichts gesagt easy
geht einfach ich hätte echt gedacht man muss die dinge
einschalten
Übrigens guck mal, wie nice die Beleuchtung von diesem Tor ist.
So richtig, so richtig passend für unter Wasser, findet ihr nicht auch?
Dass es unter Wasser genauso aussieht wie über Wasser.
Und gut beleuchtet ist.
Headcrab, hier ist bestimmt ne Headcrab drinne.
Warte mit euch, hier kommt gleich ne Headcrab.
Oder auch nicht.
Muss.
Echt nicht?
Ich hätt gedacht, die wollen uns mit irgendeiner Headcrab schocken.
Ah, gute AGP-Grafikkarte.
Bleib still.
Still bleiben.
Jetzt kommt das mit den Minen.
Jetzt muss man aufpassen.
Heli, weg!
Musste man hier nochmal nen Heli killen? Oh ne, please!
Ne, nochmal nen Heli.
Ey, ich glaub wir sind richtig, ich glaub wir sind richtig.
Hier gab's auch sonst nix.
Wenn ich das richtig im Kopf hab, man konnte hier nur durch.
Und ich glaube der Heli ist dann auch wieder...
Oh shit!
Wait a minute, hier waren so Tentakel-Teile!
Krass, da kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern.
Leute, hat jemand das Original gespielt und waren hier wirklich so Tentakel-Dinger?
Ist mir, ist mir, wow, wow, wow, ist mir komplett neu.
Tentakel-Shells.
Eieiei.
Und die Preisfrage ist auch, naja, die Preisfrage ist auch, wo muss ich denn, wo muss ich denn eigentlich hin?
Ja, mein Gott, Heli ist gut.
Ich, ich, ich, ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich hin muss.
Sag mal, hier ist, hier ist doch nix, oder?
Muss ich den, muss ich den Heli killen?
Okay, Haley ist down.
Äh, okay.
Den Tentakel kann man nicht zerstören.
Die sind un-unzerstörbar, meines Wissens nach.
Sehr schlau, Max.
Ah, da ist er wieder.
äh, okay
vielleicht
vielleicht ist es auch egal
und ich kann wieder
zurück, weil der Hilley jetzt weg ist
und ich
muss gar nicht weiter, sondern hier
ich muss hier weiter, ne
ich, ich musste da gar nicht hin
das war einfach G-Bait mit
die Map mit dem Tentakel
Oh, sind ganz schön viele.
Bam! In your face! Next!
Also
Gordon Freeman is a highly trained professional
Aber was sind denn dann die Marines hier?
Muni
Aha, Mine?
Beste Minen-Posi hinten
Off
Wie kommen wir denn hier vorbei?
So vielleicht? Ah, yes!
Es ist auch reichlich unsinnig, oder?
Au!
Es lohnt sich ja überhaupt nicht, das Zeug zu killen.
So, was haben wir denn hier gemacht? Wir haben Stormtrain Hatch...
haben wir
Plastik-Kaktus. Ach, da geht's lang!
1998 Level-Design.
Jetzt kommt das mit den Minen, genau. Minen-Stells.
Das ging so, glaube ich nicht. Ich glaube das einzige, was er machen konnte, ist...
Wir müssen da hinten hin.
Meins.
Ach, hier hätte ich auch lang gekonnt.
Hier ist der Tentakel-Shed.
Ja, meine Güte.
Im Leben wäre ich da nicht drauf gekommen,
dass ich hier langkomme.
Das ist ja...
Meine Güte, im Leben wäre ich nicht drauf gekommen, dass man hier durchkriechen kann, man.
So, jetzt müssen wir an den Minen vorbei.
Okay, hier war eine.
Okay, wo, wo, da hinten müssen wir hin.
Da müssen wir hin.
Kommen wir, kommen wir vielleicht einfach hier vorbei?
Wie haben die sich gedacht, dass man hier durchkommt?
Ah so
Okay nice
Gute Idee
Einfach Granatwerfer benutzen
Und alles in die Luft sprengen
Bam
So
Bäm!
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal ein paar snipen von hier oben.
Nein, müssen wir nicht.
Wo sind die...
Seht ihr die... wo ist die Sentry-Gun?
Da ist die Sentry-Gun down
Da oben den Headshotten wir jetzt
Das juckt ihn nicht
Aber ein Double Headshot
Juckt ihn
So
Wenn ich das richtig in Ordnung hab, muss man hier hinten rum
Oh, oh, oh
Dead
Das haben die Mod auch gut gemacht
Guck mal
Die Splattern jetzt anatomisch korrekt
Und was mir am Original auch gut gefällt ist
Das es mehr
Oh Shit
Bisschen
mal kurz, ähm, was wir im Original auch, au, wow, äh was wir im, jetzt kann ich mal den
Satz fertig machen, was mir im Original auch gut gefällt ist, dass man ein bisschen mehr
Granaten bekommt, im Vergleich zu Black Mesa, in Black Mesa bekommt man kaum Granaten für
den Granatwerfer, da hat man immer eins, zwei, ab und zu mal, aber man hat, man hat kaum,
Kaum mal 8 Stück im Granatenwerfer.
So.
Ich glaube jetzt haben wir die meisten hier clear.
Was mich übrigens extrem beeindruckt hat damals dieses Level.
Ihr müsst euch vorstellen, das ist 1997, der Max spielt sowas zum ersten Mal, ja?
Ups.
Ich hab damals nicht gecheckt,
dass das hier halt Hintergründe sind.
Ich mein, man denkt sich so,
Wie kann man das nicht checken, ist doch obvious, dass es ein Bild ist.
Ja, nicht für euch, wenn ihr das mit 13 das erste Mal spielt, das 1997 ist.
Und ich hab dann tatsächlich damals immer rumgeguckt, so
mit dem Fernglas von der
von dem Bogen so
Oh, erkennt man hier irgendwas drauf?
Man erkennt die Ränder von der Sky, oder so, ja das ist ja nicht wirklich Skybox,
Man erkennt die Ränder vom Level, wo die Textur hier so drüber gelegt und das Bild drüber gelegt wurde.
Ich mein, das Wasser und so nix bewegt sich halt.
Aber trotzdem, ich fand's damals geil.
Boah, sieht das toll aus! Außenlevel und ui!
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, ich hab Half-Life gespielt vor Unreal.
Und Unreal war damals absoluter Wahnsinn, was Außenlevel anging.
Aus heutiger Sicht, weiß ich, hat jemand von euch mal diese Castle-Demo von Unreal, die Castle-Demo von Unreal geguckt, Aua!
Kennt ihr die, kennt ihr die Unreal-Castle-Demo?
Ich, ich war so geflasht damals, als ich das erste Mal Unreal die Außenlevel gesehen hab und dann, und dann noch spiegelte Oberflächen und sowas, gab's ja in Half-Life nicht.
By the way, der Raketenwerfer sieht zwar so aus, als wäre er gut, Helis kaputt zu machen,
ist er auch, aber ganz im Ernst, das Ding hier, viel besser.
Ich bin übrigens gerade am überlegen, wie hätte man dann eigentlich korrekterweise
den Heli auf dem Damm killen sollen?
Ich glaube man weiß zu dem Zeitpunkt doch gar nicht, dass die Waffe gut gegen Helis
ist.
Warum habe ich eigentlich nur 100 FPS?
Wie kann man das anlocken?
Ich glaube gar nicht, man hätte glaube ich einfach durchrennen sollen und sich verstecken
sollen vor dem Heli.
Ich glaube storytechnisch soll es so sein, dass der Heli vom Damm der gleiche Heli ist,
der einen bis hier hin verfolgt.
Ich habe beide Helis gekillt.
Ich glaube, der Story nach war das hier der Heli vom Anfang, wir haben halt gerade drei Helis gekillt schon.
So nach dem Motto, man sollte bis hier hin fliehen vor dem Heli und hier bekommt man dann quasi die Waffe um den Heli zu killen.
Ich glaube so...
Ich hab's nicht korrekt gespielt.
Ja, aber Unreal fand ich damals so geil von den Außenleveln, aus heutiger Sicht lachst
du dich da natürlich kaputt mit so ein paar eckigen Palmen so als Bäume und sowas, aber
So hier ist ne Headcrab drinne
Alter ich sags noch und werd gehittet ne
Spawnt die er
Die spawnt erst wenn man hinguckt
Hä
Gaben
Das hat er sich höchstpersönlich ausgedacht bestimmt
Dass die erst springt wenn man reinguckt
Dass man auch schön erschreckt wird
Ja, das soll so eine Art Jumpscare sein, ja denke ich auch.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Ah, das mit den Panzern.
Okay, passt natürlich.
Game, das ist Freifeld-Game-Logik.
Wir haben einen Raketwerfer bekommen und dementsprechend haben wir selbstverständlich natürlich jetzt erst Panzer, die uns killen wollen.
...
Warte mal, komm ich hier nicht her?
Nee, oder?
So, jetzt lassen wir mal gucken, wie wir das überleben. Wir haben nämlich nicht viel.
Shit.
Alter!
Okay.
Ja, gegen den Panzer, sehr gut.
Sehr gute Idee, wie machen wir das jetzt?
Hab ich...
Okay, den Panzer kriegen wir kaputt
Wir wissen ja, dass solche Dinger auch gegen Panzer funktionieren
Hoffe ich mal, dass die auch gegen Panzer funktionieren
Shit, die funktionieren nicht gegen Panzer, okay
Okay, okay, pass auf, wir müssen jetzt rennen, wir müssen uns beeilen
Nein, nein, nein, nein, das muss Highly Trained Professional mäßig laufen.
Fuck, so schau mal nicht. Highly Trained Professional!
Alter! So.
Highly Trained Professional Style läuft das jetzt.
Okay.
Highly Trained Professional, so macht man das.
Fuck!
Okay
Next
Das war doch eigentlich schon ganz
ganz nice. Man kann die glaube ich auch
umlaufen und auf der anderen Seite rausgehen
das wäre glaube ich deutlich
deutlich schlauer
Es wäre glaube ich deutlich schlauer auf der anderen Seite rauszugehen.
Down?
Alle down?
Bam!
Panzer dead?
Ne Panzer nicht dead.
Gegner?
Moin SvenFox!
Ne SevenFox.
Panzer nicht, Dad.
Hick' noch.
Moin, Sven Fox.
Ne, Seven Fox.
NOOOOOO, GOD!
NO, GOD, PLEASE, NO!
NO!
Fuck!
Gegen die Wand geschossen beziehungsweise gegen den was weiß ich, komisches
Felddach geballert. Okay, nochmal, Highly Trained Professional Style
So langsam, langsam haben wir es doch
Okay, ich glaub der Panzer ist gleich down, jawoll, Panzer kaputt.
Alter, was ein Besacker hier.
Deadkill.
Bin nicht sicher, ob es da noch was gibt, nee, alles down, nice.
So kann man es auch machen, ich, beim besten Willen, ich glaub nicht, dass das der intended
war den den feind anzugehen warum nicht hat jemand zufällig das neue star wars
gespielt ich habe nur gehört dass es technisch überhaupt nicht richtig
ausgereift sein muss das überhaupt nicht läuft
ok feuer effekte check also ich glaube das ist was was der mod neu gemacht hat
ich glaube im original aber so viel so viel so viel schlechter sahen im
Original auch nicht aus mein das ist so viel schlechter das sieht schon ziemlich schlecht aus so
Da hinten war noch eine heal station wirklich
It's
Die hier ach stimmt die habe ich ja nicht gar nicht
jetzt
Was denkst du über diablo 4 ich habe es mir noch nicht gekauft
Also noch
Noch denke ich gar nicht so viel drüber
Aber was ich bis jetzt gelesen habe ist, dass anscheinend Blizzard es seit langer Zeit mal wieder auf die Reihe bekommen hat, ein halbwegs gescheites Game zu machen.
Hier ist noch ein Panzer.
Au!
Ey!
Richtig, richtig low IQ LLV-Driver, aber das hätten wir im Battlefield 3 besser hingekriegt,
das war definitiv kein highly trained professional.
Oh, da ist es. Geschafft!
Ladezone, jawoll.
Ey, das ist so krass, wie das lädt mit SSD.
Ich habe das gespielt 1998 oder 1997
und die Ladezeiten zwischen den Leveln waren auch schon schnell.
Aber das ist halt einfach Millisekunde Ladezeit.
Ey.
Wow!
Warum ist das Viech dead, gell?
Ah, jetzt kommen die Sniper!
Habe ich das noch richtig?
Ich glaube jetzt kommen die Sniper.
Schneipers kommen jetzt!
Ist auf für 16 ausgabe
Ja schneiders guck damit ist geschneid klein
Da wurde schon der wurde schon geschneid
Schneiders
Massive Schneiders
Guck mal, da war er schon. Habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Da ist er drin hier
Der Schneider
Äh, okay
Ey
Ich glaube, so ging das nicht, ne?
Aber man kann den hier bestimmt aufladen.
Ey, wie hat man die Snipers nochmal gekillt?
Ich glaube, man konnte die Sniper nur mit einer Granate killen.
Oh Gott, mein... ALTER!
Meine Güte, Granatphysics!
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das geklappt hat.
Nein?
Konnte man die vielleicht gar nicht killen?
Doch, dead, dead.
Aber man kann ja nicht immer eine Granate hochfeuern
jetzt wird es aber hier
Von da oben!
Gibader, äh krasser Schneider tut er.
Das Spiel passt, ja das passt 10 mal in den GPU-Rahmen bestimmt schon.
Ich bin mir nicht mehr ganz sicher wie man, oh, ach das war's jetzt, oh nein war's nicht.
Ich glaube, man muss einfach warten, bis das aufhört.
Ja, okay.
Musste man eine Granate hinschmeißen?
Ja!
Okay.
Da musst du eine Granate hinschmeißen.
Und jetzt kommt das Lagerhaus mit den vielen Minen drin.
Und irgendwo ist ein Eingang!
Von wo wird hier gesniped?
Moin!
Kannst du mich healen, Soren?
Kannst mich heilen?
Ja? 69
Jetzt müssen wir vorsichtig sein
Pass mal auf, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen
Nein, nein, nein, du bleibst mal schön hier
Du bleibst hier stehen
Pass auf, hier ist bestimmt ne Headcrab drin irgendwo
So jetzt müssen wir aufpassen, weil für alle, die das Game nicht kennen, wenn ich hier sowas in die Luft sprenge, dann passiert folgendes.
Das ganze Lagerhaus fliegt in die Luft, man ist dead.
So und ich glaube, der Intended Way, das hier zu lösen, ist so...
doch
das darf man nicht
Monarch-S
Headcrabs sind hier drinnen nicht sinnvoll
Also wir haben es ja letztens im Speedrun gesehen
Man kann ja von hier irgendwie direkt hier rein springen
Wenn man irgendwie lebensmüde ist
Aber das machen wir nicht
Wir gehen außen rum
Gucken dass wir nichts in die Luft springen
Ich glaube das hier können wir kaputt machen
Nichts dran
Hier hatten sie ab hier sieht man übrigens dass er keinen bock mehr hatten die kisten einzeln zu machen
Am anfang haben die sich noch total viel mühe gegeben so jede kiste hat hit points bekommen und alles und hier und hier hängt einfach
nur noch alles zusammen so beim einmal draufschlagen alles kaputt
So wenn ich richtig liege kann man den hier einzeln kaputt machen
Moin Juicy
so hier oben drüber kann man nicht man muss jetzt glaube hoch hier hier drunter
knapp hier drunter durch da lang die Headcrab schnell killen, rüber jumpen
das hier hoch machen und jetzt musste man einfach nur noch
Ich dachte ich habe es gebackt, ich dachte ich habe es verbackt und irgendwie funktioniert
jetzt der Aufzug nicht.
So und der hat angeblich jetzt einen zweiten Feuermodus in dem Mod, also man hat ja schon
immer diesen Feuermodus und den schnellen Feuermodus.
Und angeblich gibt es, dachte ich eigentlich, dass es für den noch einen dritten Feuermodus
gibt.
Ah doch hier, habt ihr das gesehen?
Das war so ne Biene, die ist da oben dagegen geflogen, weil das hier, das macht nämlich
überhaupt nichts.
Das wäre irgendeine Biene, die da oben was kaputt gemacht hat.
Wollen wir mal kurz gucken, ob wir ein bisschen Shields und Sachen hier drinne finden.
Nehmen wir mal das Teil, das ist aber eigentlich nur gut, wenn man sonst...
Okay, das ist definitiv ein neuer Feuermodus, den ich nicht so ganz checke, wenn ich ehrlich
bin.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Ah so, okay, das ist ein Nahkampfmodus, der schon ein bisschen suckt.
aber es scheint noch okay das ist das das ist ein neuer feuermodus der ist aber
nicht so richtig geil
guck mal der killt nicht mal eine wache mit mit einem schuss der wachmann muss
mal kurz dran glauben
oh wait a minute wenn man direkt hittet platzen die von den bienen
Okay, das ist gut zu wissen.
Nice!
Okay, das ist, das gab es im Original auch nicht.
Das haben die sich ausgedacht für den Mod, coole Sache.
Nice, ja komm mit.
Find ich gut.
Da ist ein Sentry Gun drin.
Wie ich einfach die Position noch weiß nach 20 Jahren.
What?
Okay, was genau hat mich jetzt gerade in die Luft gesprengt?
Ich war einfach zu schnell.
Loaden, loaden...
Aliens bashen...
Ist doch gar nix...
Oh doch, jetzt kommt was!
Ist doch gar nix.
Oh doch, jetzt kommt was.
Übertreib halt!
Au!
Okay, jetzt wird's close mit den Lebenspunkten, ich glaub das überlebe ich nicht.
Okay, wie kriege ich den Tank kaputt?
Wenn ich Glück habe, wenn ich viel Glück habe...
Okay wir lassen die sich erstmal hier oben jetzt kloppen miteinander.
So.
Und Tschüss und Tschüss und Tschüss.
Nix mehr.
Wach man.
Weg da.
Oh oh.
Der kriegt auf den Sack.
Ja der hat..
Das lief nicht so gut.
Ich hab echt ein Problem. Ich hab kein...
Ich hab kein Anti-Tank-Ding mehr.
Okay, wir müssen uns beeilen.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Fuck. Okay. Ich hab ne Idee.
Wir müssen durch.
Wir müssen durch, bevor...
das hier alles kaputt geht.
Genau. Nice, nice, nice, nice.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Okay, vielleicht
Warte mal, wir saven mal.
Vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Jawoll!
Ey!
Ich brauch das
gegen den Panzer, Mensch!
Hoffe mal, dass das reicht.
Shit.
Okay, wir haben ein Problem.
Wie kriegen wir den Panzer kaputt?
Vielleicht, okay,
vielleicht müssen wir einfach nur schnell sein.
Wait a minute!
Wait a minute, mit der Shotgun hab ich...
Na gut, ich will mich jetzt mal nicht beschweren.
Ich hab keinen Panzer mit der Shotgun in die Luft gesprengt.
Geiler Panzer, oder?
Ich fürchte, das war nicht der intended way.
Wir haben halt nur noch 13% Leben jetzt, aber gut.
ich hab halt noch ein prozent leben da oben ist da oben ist ein schneider
ok schneider ließ sterben
ich hoffe dass der schneider weil das muss jetzt ein bisschen vorsichtiger
angehen
Wir haben nämlich nur 13, 13 Leben. Achtung, Schneiber, Schneiber-Action.
Dead?
Mensch!
Auf, komm um die Ecke. Kommt her.
Was geht denn da drinnen grad ab?
Was geht da oben grad ab?
Oh shit, wir haben ein Problem.
Oh, close!
So, ich glaube hier ist jetzt Leben drinnen.
Money as fuck ist hier drinne. Ich bräuchte. Das hier. So erstmal alles durchladen. Weil
hier haben wir jetzt quasi unendlich Money für alles. Jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal
wir uns erstmal aufladen. So hier das da nachladen, Bogen nachladen, Dings nachladen, da haben wir.
Ich glaube, ich glaube mehr gibt es hier nicht.
Das war's aber dafür sind wir gut gut ausgerüstet
Achtung, BÄM, war das wirklich so klein im, was ist da, was ist da los, war das wirklich
so klein im Original, ich bilde mir auch ein, dass die Waffenkammer viel größer war und
ich bilde mir auch ein, man musste irgendwie, ach ne hier war das, ah das haben die in Black
verbessert
ich glaube in Black Mesa muss man dann
durch die Waffenkammer und so durch
ok
wenn hier ein Sniper noch drin ist bin ich
gefickt
ok anscheinend kein Sniper
kein Sniper mehr
mal schauen wie wir die Soldaten da unten
Kaputt kriegen
Normalerweise da ist er doch da ist er doch da steht auch einer
Ich finde sie ein bisschen befremdlich dass die headshots überleben mittlerweile
Oder war ich einfach nicht auf dem kopf drauf kann auch sein
Dead? Fragezeichen? Alles dead?
Wie? Wirklich? Mehr gab es da nicht?
Nice! Nice Jumpskills Max!
gibt es gibt es vielleicht hier irgendwie ein bisschen so ein bisschen so ein bisschen
leben vielleicht das ist alles ah yes nice ok dann hat sich sogar gelohnt hier hinzugehen
Stellt sich nur die Frage, wie kommt man hier rauf?
So?
Ah, Half-Life-Logik.
So, und das Ganze, please, jetzt ohne...
Nice, ohne Damage zu nehmen, Pog!
Was, die haben kurz FFA oben gemacht, ja.
Sah so aus. Ich hab nur noch die Überreste aufgeräumt.
Hallo.
Oh oh.
Nope, lasst mich in Ruhe. Und tschüss.
Ich bin weg.
Ich hab viel zu wenig Leben.
Fuck.
Ah!
Ich habe zwölf Leben, wie stellt ihr euch das denn vor?
Hallo
Okay, jetzt kann ich das Vieh. Vieh, ich komme mal her, ich muss dich in die Luft sprengen.
Oh oh, nein, ich bin down. Shit, ich war zu langsam.
Ist es tot?
Jawohl
So jetzt muss ich...
die Tür kaputt machen?
Oh shit shit shit shit shit
Max das war blöd
so ich hoffe dass alles dad ist weil mit zwölf leben komme ich hier nicht so
weit gibt es hier nicht irgendwo noch was nein vor zwölf leben
einig train professionals
shit
Ich brauch auf jeden Fall Leben. Leben und Schild. Jawoll! Perfekt!
Es ist so...
Ja gut, das ist easy, die haben mich gebaited, ich muss einfach warten bis die hier rankommen,
ja das ist easy.
Es ist übrigens nicht gedacht, fuck man, ok das muss, das muss anders gehen.
Shit, das funktioniert nicht, ich hab zu wenig Leben dafür.
Okay, pass mal auf, Trick 17.
Wir schaffen das, wir schaffen das. Easy, easy, easy.
Okay, jetzt ran. Ran, ran, ran, ran, ran. Gib ihm.
Ey, was ist das?
Ok, das ist nix, das funktioniert so nicht.
Das, das, das funktioniert so nicht.
Wir müssen Munition verschwenden, Leute. Es geht nicht anders.
Wir müssen Munition verschwenden. Ich bin... Ich bin two-shot von denen.
Wenn ich jetzt auch ordentlich spielen würde, wäre halt auch nice.
Können die mal aufhören zu spawnen?
Die Kugel ist in der Kugel.
Ja.
Und jetzt haben wir sieben leben es wird es wird ja immer besser
Frage im chat sagt hi max würdest du auch auf drei tage die woche arbeit gehen wenn du 50k bekommen würdest
wie jetzt
du meinst 50k für drei tage
also also du meinst ja nicht 50k weniger
Also 50k...
Keine Ahnung...
50k kommt man raus, ja...
Weiß aber nicht, es scheint mir ein bisschen...
Scheint mir dann vielleicht doch ein bisschen knapp, aber ja, ich mein...
Ich würd's mir überlegen.
Lass mal überlegen, wie viel verdien ich eigentlich?
Wie viel würde ich verdienen in...
Mit drei Tagen?
Drei Tage sind 40 40 40 Prozent Reduktion oder?
Ne, doch, doch.
Ich, ich, ich müsste so 55, 60K irgendwie, irgendwie in dem Dreh haben mit drei Tagen.
Also ja, vielleicht, also da habe ich mir noch keine, da habe ich...
Da habe ich mir noch keine großen Gedanken zu gemacht bisher. Das stand für mich jetzt noch nicht zur Diskussion.
Vielleicht, ja. Also wenn's mich... Also ich würde...
Okay, was jetzt? Alter! Alter, ich hab noch sieben! Leute, ich hab noch sieben Leben!
Vielleicht, ja. Also wenn's mich... Also ich würde das...
Okay, was jetzt? Alter! Alter, ich hab noch sieben!
Leute, ich hab noch sieben Leben!
Ich hab noch sieben Leben, jetzt macht mal...
...macht mal ein bisschen sanft hier.
Also ich würde, ich, ich würde das... Fuck, ich komm hier nicht dran. Kann man vielleicht das hier schieben. Oder kann man, so kann man machen, ne?
Ähm, also ich würde das vielleicht in Erwägung ziehen, sollte mir, sollte es mir irgendwie auf den Sack gehen.
Komm ich denn da dran, Leute? Habt ihr irgendwie ne schlaue Idee?
Nice Physics!
Na, excellent, Leute! Das ist immer geiler Physics hier!
Steuerung beim Springen mach ich schon, guck!
Reicht nicht.
Kommt man nicht dran.
Ich bin zumindest zu blöd.
Ich hätte die Kiste vorher runterschieben müssen, oder?
Leute, ich hätte die Kiste...
Shit, ich kann das nicht mehr lernen.
Ich hätte die Kiste vorher runterschmeißen müssen.
Und dann wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
Wie soll ich denn das nächste mit 27 Leben überstehen?
Also nicht das hier.
Also nicht das hier!
Jetzt kommt das gleich, wo ich aus dem Lüftungsschacht abgeschossen werde!
Wie soll ich das mit 27 Leben überleben?
Das ist...
Das wird nix!
Nicht getro- Just, just survive.
Nicht getroffen werden.
Vorher.
Ja.
So machen wir das.
Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi- Wi-
Wir just bashen die jetzt.
Okay, ich hab das schwere in Erinnerung jetzt mit dem Lüftungsschacht hier, ich dachte
eigentlich da sind jetzt 20 Gegner, aber es waren anscheinend nur 2.
Das muss ich ausprobieren, Leute.
Ha, wusste ichs doch!
Man kommt da durch, wenn man schnell genug ist.
Es war jetzt ziemlich pp-iger von mir, weil ich unsinnig viel Ammo verschwendet habe.
Das muss ich aber trotzdem machen.
Ich muss das...
Das finde ich geil.
Ich verliere viel zu viel Leben.
Auf der anderen... Sag mal, bin ich jetzt logged, weil ich hier nicht wegkomme? Oder kann ich das hier einschießen?
Ich bin nicht gelockt auf der anderen seite ist der sinn es macht doch überhaupt keinen sinn oder
Weil weil ich kann doch einfach auch hier lang
Ja genau easy
Ja dann
Muss ich die Bühne nur mal runterfahren?
So, wie machen wir die jetzt?
Wie machen wir die jetzt?
Mit dem Bogen am besten
Was war das?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Alter, was zum...
Hey!
Du Cheater alter! Du hast nen Shotgun! Mit der Shotgun kannst du überhaupt keine Granaten mehr erschießen.
Okay, jetzt sind wir wieder an der gleichen Stelle hier.
Leute, ich hol mir mal kurz was zu essen.
Sekt.
Oh, ich muss mal kurz...
...anmachen, damit ich, äh...
Ich hol mir mal kurz was zu essen.
Bin gleich wieder da.
Wir spielen das noch weiter, ich...
Macht übelst Bock mal wieder Half-Life zu spielen. Bin gleich wieder da.
Das war's für heute, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bleibt sauber, haut rein und wir sehen uns im nächsten Video, tschüss!
So, da bin ich wieder.
Habt ihr irgendeinen Vorschlag, was wir uns angucken können, während ich was esse?
Ich hab jetzt, ich hab übelst Hunger.
Wir spielen gleich weiter.
Lasst mal kurz schauen.
Was haben wir denn hier noch?
Wir können uns mal ein aktuelles Video angucken.
Was gibt's?
Es gibt Reis mit Hackfleisch
und zwei stücker brot dabei
Was haben wir denn hier chat gpt for all
Your own chat gibt. Okay, das kommen wir uns morgen früh angucken was verdient ein op assistent
Also was haben wir hier? Awesome Webvideos. Fireship
Wir kommen uns Fireship an. Fireship macht gute Videos
Nicht wundern Half-Life geht gleich weiter jetzt erst mal essen break
...
...longer to say WWW than it does to just say World Wide Web.
And that one little change could add...
Ja, ich verstehe, das sind ja auch die Amis, die WWW sagen.
Die sind ja auch nicht mal ganz dicht, wir sagen einfach WWW.
...hundreds of milliseconds to your productivity.
Had I known that 15 years ago, I'd probably have my own space exploration company by now.
But instead, I'm still just building crappy websites.
Okay, ich ess mal den Ball.
While we've all been distracted by the terrifyingly overhyped rise of artificial intelligence,
Die Webplattform hat ein paar spielverändernde neue Features eingeladen, die ihr wahrscheinlich noch nicht gehört habt und die den Weg, wie wir Webseiten bauen, für immer verändern werden.
Und das ist nicht mal Hyperbole.
Die erste Feature auf dieser Liste ist Huge.
Der native HTML-Dialog.
Ich habe zuerst diese Feature vor einem Jahr erwähnt, aber jetzt ist sie vollständig unterstützt auf allen großen Browsern.
Und was sie macht, ist, dass es viel einfacher ist...
Moment, gucken wir mal, ob Safari auch kann.
Kann Safari...
Okay, krass.
Safari kann ja eigentlich nix sonst.
...Feature vor einem Jahr, aber jetzt ist sie vollständig unterstützt auf allen großen Browsern.
Und was es macht, ist, dass es viel einfacher ist,
Lass mich raten, der letzte Browser war Safari, der es unterstützt hat,
um deine eigenen Modal-Wände zu bauen.
Normalerweise, um einen Modal von Anfang an zu bauen,
brauchst du eine volle Software.
Ich habe zu Beginn dieses Feature vor etwa einem Jahr erwähnt,
aber jetzt ist es auf allen großen Browsern vollständig unterstützt.
Und was es macht, ist, dass es viel einfacher ist, deine eigenen Modal-Wände zu bauen.
Normalerweise, um einen Modal von Anfang an zu bauen, brauchst du einen Vollscreen-Backdrop,
dann eine Wände, die auf dem Modal sitzt, und ein paar Passwort-Javascripts,
um diese Elemente zu zeigen und zu verstecken.
Es hat sich immer viel schwieriger gefühlt, als es sollte sein.
Aber jetzt haben wir den Dialog, welcher nur ein regulärer HTML-Element ist,
den man mit seiner ID bezeichnen kann,
und hat ein paar gebaute Javascript-Methoden, um es zu zeigen und zu verstecken.
Zum Beispiel, um den Modal zu zeigen, können wir den ShowModal-Method ausführen,
und er erscheint magisch in der UI mit einem Backdrop.
The backdrop itself has its own pseudo-element that can be styled with CSS.
We can then close the modal by either submitting a form inside of it with a method of dialogue,
or by calling its...
Wenn wir mal kurz den Titel anders...
Titel vom Stream wird jetzt einfach...
PeopleFat
Just Chatting
Wir machen gleich Weihnachten.
... its closed method on some other event.
This makes life so much easier, because you can animate it using simple CSS transitions.
And speaking of making your life easier, today's sponsor is Qlrk,
who provides the most beautiful user authentication solution I've ever seen.
By drawing a different sign, developers can easily access the current user.
... take weeks to roll ...
... these can ...
... features experimental ...
Ich skippe das mal kurz. Okay, was kommt als nächstes? Zweitens.
... popover.
Luckily, native popovers are also coming to the web.
As of today this feature is experimental, so you'll need to enable it with a flag,
but basically it provides a couple of attributes like popover target and popover, which allows
you to show and hide content without the need to write any JavaScript or tricky CSS that
uses focus within.
Just match the element ID to the popover target and you're done.
That'll be a nice quality of life improvement, but the next feature, WebGPU, is easily the
most important feature on this list, even if you never use it.
Sie ist im Grunde genommen der Nachfolger von WebGL, der Browsern und Web-Apps ermöglicht.
Warte, WebGL ist kein Ding mehr oder was?
WebGL ist outdated, overrated, gebatet jetzt mittlerweile?
Oder wie ist das?
Ich dachte, das ist immer noch voll angesagt.
...to take advantage of GPUs.
It is under an experimental flag today,
but many libraries like Babylon.js fully support it already
and support for 3.js is underway.
And that means 3D graphics and games are about to get way faster on the web.
I'm using it right now with Babylon.js
Und wie ihr seht, ist die Web-GPU-Version viel majestärischer.
Und nicht nur das, aber auch Librarien wie TensorFlow.js unterstützen es,
was bedeutet, dass Entwickler Web-Apps bauen können,
in denen End-User Maschinen-Learning-Modelle trainieren können,
ohne die Bedürfnis, ein paar Python-Librarie zu downloaden oder ein Notebook in der Cloud zu benutzen.
Das ist ziemlich cool, aber für die meisten Web-Entwickler ist das größte Herausforderung,
gute CSS zu schreiben.
Als nächstes haben wir Container-Queries.
Um responsive Webseiten zu bauen, benutzen Entwickler oft Media-Queries,
in denen verschiedene Stile zu einem Element angepasst werden,
aufgrund der Größe des Viewports.
Okay, das ist jetzt zu high IQ für mich. Ich habe keine Ahnung von CSS-Styling.
Max, sag mal, taugt das was? Ist das ein gutes Feature?
Ich habe keinen Plan.
Container Query Width and Height that allow you to compute the proper size of the children directly in the CSS.
In the past you might run into situations where you have to actually get the bounding box from JavaScript,
then solve some crazy differential equations to get the div in the right place.
And you'll be happy to know that there's an official Tailwind Container Queries package
that allows you to declare these containers directly in your HTML.
Another cool CSS feature you might not know about is Color Mix.
I've used tools like Sass to mix colors in the past, but now we can do it natively in CSS.
Es ist eine Funktion, die zwei Farben-Argumente nimmt und sie in einem bestimmten Farbenspaß vermischt.
Wie in diesem Beispiel, wenn wir Rot und Blau vermischen.
Wenn wir Blau in einem RGB-Farben-Spaß nehmen, bekommen wir als Ergebnis Purpel.
Das ist nicht sehr nützlich alleine, aber es macht es einfacher, Effekte wie diese zu machen,
wo ich eine Liste von Itemen habe, die Rot und Weiß zusammen vermischen,
um einen Gradient-Effekt zu erzeugen, der über mehrere Elemente erfolgt.
Aber sprechen wir über Features von Sass, ein weiterer riesiger ist CSS-Nesting.
Ich kann nicht glauben, dass es so lange dauert, aber es ist fast vollständig unterstützt in allen modernen Browsern.
Es ist purely ein ergonomisches...
Was ist da los?
Das ist eigentlich nicht möglich.
Ahhh.
Man kann sie jetzt nesten an... aber...
Achso.
Ok, dann erkennt man die Struktur besser.
Man kann jetzt hier direkt, okay, okay, ja, das ist cool, das ist gut, das gefällt mir.
Oh, das brauche ich.
Das war sehr hacky, immer Schriftarten mit Outlines zu machen und sowas im Browser.
Das ist ja Pog, das wichtigste Feature überhaupt.
single glyph.
This opens up a whole new world of possibilities, because now you can customize the entire color
palette of a font, and create some crazy effects like 3D gradients.
What's cool about this is that they're still interpreted as regular fonts in the browser.
Whereas previously, stuff like this would only be possible with your own custom vector graphics.
There are only a few color fonts at the moment, but it will be interesting to see what else
comes out in the future.
But the next thing I want to look at is performance, and the new Web Vitals plugin for Chrome.
Du kannst die Leistung eines Websites mit einem Lighthouse-Report auswählen, aber der Prozess ist etwas langsam und kompliziert.
Dieses Plugin wird die Leistungsmetriken des Consoles logieren, während du ein Website benutzt.
Und es kann Leistungsprobleme wie Layout-Shift auswählen und dich zu dem exakten Element hinweisen, der das Problem verursacht.
In der Webentwicklung ist einfach komplett, äh, Six-Set-Time.
Es gibt eine Menge Dinge, die man beachten muss, wenn es um Leistung geht,
und ich habe ein Video über das Thema auf meinem zweiten Kanal, wenn du mehr lernen möchtest.
Aber jetzt ist es an der Zeit, über neue JavaScript-Features zu sprechen, wie ArrayAt.
Wenn du aus einem Sprache wie Python kommst,
Wie, guck mal, der ist jetzt beim neunten Punkt.
Wie will der bis zu 21 kommen, in noch drei Minuten?
... or most other languages for that matter.
You might find it absurd that to get the last element in a JavaScript array,
you have to take the array length and subtract one.
You can't just use negative one or last.
Until now...
Ich bin nicht surprised, das ist JavaScript.
... that makes this code obsolete.
Now we can just say at negative one to get the last element.
Or second to last with negative two.
That's pretty cool, but deep copy is even more useful.
Eine Sache, die ihr endlich machen müsst, ist, ein Objekt zu kopieren.
In JavaScript werden Objekte durch Referenz überwiesen,
was bedeutet, dass, wenn man einen zu einem neuen Variablen einstellt,
ihr den selben ursprünglichen Objekt nochmals referenzieren werdet.
Wenn ihr eine Eigenschaft auf B modifiziert,
wird es auch die Eigenschaft auf A modifizieren,
weil sie der selben Objekt-Referenz sind.
Die meiste Zeit benutzen wir den Objekt-Assign oder die Spread-Syntax,
um ein neues Objekt zu kreieren,
aber das Problem hier ist, dass es nur eine scharfe Kopie gibt,
was bedeutet, dass, wenn ein Objekt eine Menge Objekte hat,
diese Mengen Objekte nochmals die Referenz zu ihrem ursprünglichen Objekt behalten werden.
Aber in vielen Fällen ist das nicht das, was du willst.
Und was Entwickler seit Jahren tun, ist, JSON-Stringify zu benutzen, um das Objekt in eine Stringe zu drehen,
und dann JSON-Parse, um es zurück in ein Objekt zu parsieren.
Das ist ein völlig verrücktes Hack, das eine neue Objekt-Referenz in die Erinnerung kreiert.
Aber ich bin froh, zu berichten, dass das Leben nicht so sein muss.
Es gibt jetzt eine globale Funktion namens Structured Clone, die ein Objekt klonen kann.
Also ehrlich?
Hätte ich gesehen, Structured Clone in JavaScript.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das was Build-In ist, unter dem Namen und so,
Sondern irgendwas aus dem der Library
Was ist hier los? Wir spielen gleich Half-Life weiter
Ich mach grad Essenspause
...into a new reference
Making it way easier to transfer data
from one object to another
And that gives us 10 awesome new web features
to take advantage of. But wait, there's more
Like the transform stream interface
that allows you to pop one fetch call into another
Or how about import maps
that allow you to
...stream interface that allows you to
...
Was bin ich hier sehen gerade?
Was?
Response?
Body?
Pipe through?
Okay, just Javascript, Digga.
Kannst auch immer, werde ich wahrscheinlich nie brauchen.
property, which you might use to make the first letter in an article bigger, just like
in a magazine.
I should also probably mention new viewport units, designed specifically for mobile, that
can take into account if toolbars are opened or not.
Also let's not forget focus visible, that can take into account if toolbars are opened
or not.
Also let's not forget focus visible, which is a more accessibility friendly way to handle
focus and form inputs and buttons.
Speaking of focus, there's also now an inert property that you can use on elements to show
they lack the ability to move or be focused on.
That one's kinda boring, but a way more exciting experimental technology is the View Transitions
API, which allows developers to create animations between webpages to make websites behave more
like mobile apps that keep the user in context.
And finally we have Animation Timeline.
As of today it's experimental, but it gives you the ability to control animations based
on the scroll position in the browser.
Ohne Scheiß Leute, Browser sind mittlerweile, und das meine ich ernst, das ist jetzt kein
Witz, nicht mal zur Hälfte.
sind mehr komplex als Betriebssysteme mittlerweile.
Everybody does, but always feels way more complicated than it should be.
And with that, we've looked at 21 new features on the web.
If you knew every single one of them, congratulations, you just won the grand prize.
One free web development job, redeemable at the company of your choosing.
Just present this certificate during your interview, and they should let you write in
no questions asked.
Dankeschön fürs Zuschauen und wir sehen uns im nächsten Video.
Es war fast unmöglich, für die ersten Tage auf der Webseite der Healthcare.gov zu abonnieren.
Ich habe noch irgendetwas interessantes, was man sich angucken kann.
Bald ist auch Apple Developer Conference, glaube nächste Woche Dienstag oder so.
Website, einfach einen Installer runter, starten, zack, und schon läuft ein JGBT-Klon auf
meinem rechner der nicht machen die noch andere videos außer item bei der ct
wirst du den battle bit final play was ist denn ein final playtest bevor es early access wird
oder wie man mit dem internet verbunden sein muss also wirklich komplett lokal läuft gpt for all
heißt das ganze open source ist es auch und die software lädt sogar für euch die sprachmodelle
runter. Komplett automatisch. Laut eines geliebten Google Dokuments ist genau sowas für Google die
größte Konkurrenz. Nicht OpenAI und nicht Microsoft, sondern die Open Source Gemeinde,
die gerade in einem Wahnsinns Tempo aufholt. Ich gucke mir GPT4ALL und die Open Source Sprachmodelle
mal genauer an. Sind die schon vergleichbar mit den kommerziellen? Sind die überhaupt
wirklich Open Source? Bleibt dran.
Können wir uns später angucken, Max.
Lieber Erkan, lieber Internet-Surfer, herzlich willkommen hier, bye.
Ich bin grad fertig essen.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von NordPass. Ihr kennt das vielleicht, in eurer Firma müsst
ihr ständig irgendwelchen Zugängen und Passwörtern hinterher rennen, beziehungsweise wenn ihr
selbst ne Firma habt, ist das alles mit viel Aufwand verbunden.
Was für'n Teufel ist NordPass?
Ist das der Passwortmanager von NordVPN?
Warum sollte ich um alles in der Welt einen Passwortmanager von NordVPN benutzen?
Bin ich dann...
Bin ich des Wahnsinns oder was?
Bin ich verrückt?
Gibt schon lange.
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht warum man sowas benutzen sollte.
Ich weiß, wir haben schon mal ein Video gemacht zu einer lokal lauffähigen Text KI, das war
aber ein ziemlich frickelig zu installierende Hack namens DALAI.
Vor allem musste man hier manuell mit den mehrere Gigabyte großen Sprachmodell Dateien
herum hantieren.
Inzwischen sind zwei Monate vergangen, in der hyperbeschleunigten KI Welt entspricht
das ungefähr zwei Normaljahren, das ist ein bisschen so wie mit Hundejahren und Menschenjahren.
Kleiner Dad Joke, aber ernsthaft.
Jetzt gibt es GPT4ALL und ganz viele neue Sprachmodelle.
Und der Unterschied zu DALEI vor zwei Monaten ist immens.
Alleine die Installation.
Einfach den Installer von GPT4ALL.io herunterladen, installieren, starten
und dann in der Software auf Download gehen und...
Jetzt nur noch den Reis reinhauen und dann geht's weiter.
Man kann hier einfach mehr als 10 Sprachmodelle mit einem Klick herunterladen.
Das Ganze läuft auf Windows, Linux und macOS.
Ja, und die Qualität der Ausgabe ist zumindest bei einigen Sprachmodellen
auch deutlich besser als noch bei denen, die von Dalai unterstützt wurden.
Stellt man zum Beispiel eine einfache Sachfrage wie zum Beispiel
welcher Roman von Thomas Mann spielt auf einem Berg,
dann bekommt man vom zurzeit wohl besten GPT4ALL Sprachmodell Snoozy
die klare Antwort Ja, der Zauberberg.
Und wenn man fragt Von wann ist der?
Erschließt das System auch aus dem Kontext, um was es geht und spuckt 1924 aus.
Google kann ja auf solche Sachfragen oft nicht konkret antworten, sondern zeigt dann meist nur eine Textstelle aus dem Netz an.
Und vor allem benötigt Google ja auch eine Internetverbindung.
GPT4ALL nicht.
Also, können ja auch ein Flugzeug benutzen oder sonst wo.
Andere von GPT4ALL und den verschiedenen Sparkmodellen hauen allerdings richtigen Mumpits raus.
Sehr schön fand ich als auf die Frage, welcher Thomas-Mann-Roman spielt auf einem Berg.
Die Antwort kam, ja, das ist der Titel des Romans von Weilche im Jahr 1882.
Oder kennt ihr schon die dollste Touristenattraktion in Hannover, Schloss Neuschwanstein?
Tatsächlich machen viele der Sprachmodelle sogar heftige Rechtschreib- und Grammatikfehler.
Das ist mir mit Chet, GPT, Bing und Bart nie passiert.
Aber wie gesagt, das Snoozy-Sprachmodell und das Wikuna-Modell, beide mit 13 Milliarden Parametern,
liefern echt ganz ordentliche Ergebnisse.
Sogar unseren 3003 KI-Benchmark schaffen sie.
Erzähle einen Witz, in dem ein Raspberry Pi, Martin Luther und ein Schokokuchen vorkommen.
Joa.
Die Geschwindigkeit der Ausgabe ist natürlich sehr stark vom verwendeten Rechner abhängig.
GPT4ALL nutzt standardmäßig nicht die Grafikeinheit, sondern den AVX2 Befehlssatz der CPU.
Und CPUs ab ca.
Da dreht der Lüfter ordentlich hoch dann.
2014 können das, gibt aber auch eine GPT4ALL Version für den älteren AVX, also ohne 2 Befehlssatz.
Sehr schnell lief GPT4ALL bei meinen Tests auf einem MacBook Pro mit M.2 Max,
Aber auch auf dem Windows PC mit AMD 3700X Prozessor war die Geschwindigkeit okay.
Nur auf einem ziemlich alten PC mit Intel i7 6700K machte das keinen Spaß.
Das sah dann so aus.
Ja, aber wo kommen denn die Sprachmodelle eigentlich her?
Und hier kommt jetzt mal ein kleiner Einschub.
Und keine Angst, das wird nicht so komplett.
Wahrscheinlich vom GitHub, oder?
Also die Technik von ChatGPT basiert auf sogenannten Large Language Models, LLMs.
Das sind neuronale Netze, in die riesige Textmengen hineingekippt werden.
Das Generieren von einem Sprachmodell nennt sich Pre-Training.
Und das ist ziemlich aufwendig.
Wir sprechen hier von tausenden Profi-GPUs, die wochenlang rechnen.
Und das kann dann schon mal mehrere Millionen Euro kosten.
Man darf sich aber nicht vorstellen, dass da dann einfach ein Chatbot hinten rauspurzelt.
Denn so ein Large-Language-Model ist kein Chatbot, sondern nur die Basis dafür.
Man muss das LLM noch auf den vorgesehenen Einsatzzweck nachtrainieren,
Also zum Beispiel Texte einfach vervollständigen oder Fragen beantworten.
Und Letzteres würde man ja für den Chatbot machen.
Wenn ihr euch zum Beispiel ChatGPT und Microsoft Bing anguckt,
die nutzen beide das nicht offene GPT4 LLM von OpenAI,
aber fühlen sich in der Praxis ganz unterschiedlich an,
eben weil sie unterschiedlich nachtrainiert wurden.
Zu beiden haben wir hier schon Videos gemacht.
Die Grund LLMs werden manchmal auch Foundation Models genannt,
weil sie quasi das Fundament sind, die Basis für spätere Anwendungen.
Das Nachtrainieren, um zum Beispiel einen Chatbot zu bekommen, nennt man Fine-Tuning.
Das ist deutlich weniger aufwendig als das vorangehende Pre-Training.
Um so ein Large-Language-Modell zu entwickeln,
Fertig essen.
Na ja, so halb.
Letzte muss ich noch runterstopfen.
Dann geht's weiter.
Ich geh noch mal kurz aufs Klo vorher.
Hierbei lass ich ein Update von meinem Arch-Trainingslaufen.
Wer jetzt dazu gekommen ist, wir sind gerade auf dem Weg zum Lambda-Komplex und müssten
glaube ich auch demnächst da sein und Richtung Xen gehen.
Ja, ihr könnt euch noch mal kurz ne Runde Fische angucken und bisschen Musik, ja, exzellent.
Bin gleich wieder da, geh noch mal kurz aufs Klo.
Übersetzung & Untertitel Angela Dorn
Sprecher Jochen Graf
Deutsche Bearbeitung sub&dub company
Redaktion Miriam Selle
Team-Release von Dolphin Game Nintendo sagt, nein.
Okay, ich vermute mal, das ist keine rechtliche Sache, sondern eher so ne...
...äh, wir können auf unserer Plattform machen, was wir wollen, weil...
...Emulation an sich ist ja nicht illegal.
Aber klar, wenn Valve sagt, gibt's nicht, gibt's nicht.
Es ist halt so. Man kann man...
...kann man sich jetzt drüber aufregen, aber im Endeffekt...
...kannste nix machen, die können ja auf ihrer Plattform treiben, was sie...was sie lustig sind.
Okay, das war komplett Verschwendung von der Kramata, aber ich wollte einfach die drei Headcrabs gerade splattern.
It's Half-Life, lighter physics, lighter physics.
Leichtere Physik, ja da geht es dann hier weiter, war hier neben vielleicht noch was?
Ey, hier kommen wir her.
Ja, das siehste halt, wahrscheinlich gehen die zusammen Golf spielen.
Leute von Nintendo, Leute von Microsoft, Leute von Valve oder was auch immer man so macht
in diesen Kreisen und dann wird sowas auf dem kleinen Dienstweg geklärt und dann sagt
der jeweilige Plattformbetreiber halt, nö, gibts nicht und da kannst du halt nix dagegen
machen. Die können in ihrer Plattform ja im Endeffekt machen was sie wollen und tja, Pech gehabt da.
Da hast du gelitten.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Leute wir haben gleich 100% Leben.
Ah, shit.
Knapp.
Close.
Den brauchen wir zum Türaufmachen, vermute ich.
Wir können einfach überprüfen, ob man den Typ zum Türaufmachen braucht.
Ja, man braucht ihn zum Türaufmachen.
Sonst wäre das Game jetzt nicht...
Game over gegangen.
Jetzt wird dieserAufstandszeil hereingehen
Ja wir hätten vielleicht eine Zweifelschance, wenn wir zusammenstierten
Die sind ziemlich tanky die Viecher. Ich würde mir auch einen im Original, die haben hier nicht so viel ausgehalten.
Okay Barney, einmal öffnen, please.
So und hier gibt es diesen Bug, das machen wir jetzt nicht und wahrscheinlich ist der wie gesagt auch gefixt in HM-Mod.
Wenn man sich hier in die Tür klitscht, kriegt man... die Tür macht negativ Schaden und dann hat man doch endlich Leben, wenn man eine Weile drinsteht.
Oh, jetzt kommt das Viech! Ich erinnere mich! Jawoll! Nix wie weg!
Normalerweise wird man jetzt hier verfolgt, aber ich bin zu schnell. Ich tue mal so, als wäre ich... ich lasse mich mal verfolgen, dass es dramatischer wirkt.
Das Viech hat es nicht gecheckt, ich war zu schnell.
Komm her!
Ja komm, auf!
Oh nein, ich werde verfolgt!
Mon KS!
Au!
Okay, ich war wirklich ein bisschen zu lahm.
Oh shit, das war...
Sehr schlau Max, sehr schlau.
Excellent, high IQ.
So jetzt aber, auf komm her, ich speichere doch sonst immer alle 5 Meter, jetzt habe
ich natürlich nicht gespeichert.
Oh, jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
So, jetzt muss man hier rüber, ins Wasser.
Oh, ins Wasser, hier hoch.
Und jetzt fällt man erstmal runter, weil man extremly pp-iger ist.
Und jetzt muss man das Teil kaputtbomben mit irgendeiner komischen Steuerung die die ok ok
Moment wo ist das ok das ist in Black Mesa natürlich deutlich angenehmer
Das ist in Black Mesa deutlich angenehmer gemacht ich hoffe ich
So das sollte jetzt hier irgendwo einschlagen.
Woah, warte mal, seit wann kann das Viech da hoch?
Boah!
Teil 1 kann das Fiecht auch!
Man muss... Warte mal!
Man muss das Ding doch gar nicht killen, oder?
Man kann doch einfach auf... What the?
What?
Alter, was hab ich denn hier für ne...
für krasse Speicher
für Pegaspeicher
Guck mal, es reicht doch glaube ich
wenn man
das hier hinten aufsprengt, genau
so und jetzt
einfach nur
volle Pulle
Dahinter rennt, man braucht das Viech glaube ich gar nicht zu killen.
Äh, wie kann man nochmal da drüber?
Ah, den Mast umschießen, ich erinnere mich.
Ja, das kann so bleiben.
Den Mast umschießen.
Oh, ich bin der ich bin ich bin ich bin der oder auch nicht
Muss man nicht den master jetzt drauf stürzen lassen
Alter die die steuerung macht mich fertig
Shit, man.
Alter, das Viech regt mich auf.
So, komm mal hier rüber.
Komm mal, komm mal, nein, nein, nein, komm mal hier rüber, komm mal hier rüber.
So, komm mal her.
Ja, perfekt. Hier, hier her.
Exzellent.
Du kannst hier doch eh nicht hin.
Genau, lauf mal schön außen rum.
So, und wenn du außen rumgelaufen bist...
halt die steuerung dann schauen wir das hier das ist noch gar nicht offen dahinten
warum ist das nicht auf
Guck mal, wie einfach das mein Chip ist, wie man das Chip ändern kann.
Ah, jetzt ist es auf.
Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal, wie einfach man das debaten kann.
Echtes Bepega-Viech.
Ich glaube an der Stelle jetzt kommt erstmal, jetzt kommt diese komische Sequenz, wo man
über die Felsen springen muss, glaube ich.
Ja, genau.
Die man aber einfach umgehen kann,
wenn man
so springt.
Also normalerweise soll man jetzt
hier quasi so
So dem ganzen Zeug ausweichen und dann halt irgendwie da durchgehen.
So jetzt fahren wir mal die Sentry Guns aus.
Oh oh, blöde Idee die Sentry Gun auszufahren.
Die Sentry-Gun muss man eigentlich ausfahren, wenn man die Viecher hier gespawnt hat.
auf komm her her kommen komplett sinnlos das fiech wir machen die sentry gunner aus und
Der wird einfach mit der Armbrust gebasht
Oh, das sind zwei, shit
Wow, close
Wo ist das Viech? Wo ist das Viech? Komm her
Beschreckt
Wow!
Hinter mir ist gerade einfach was gespawnt, hat mich instant gebasht.
Schön ins Auge.
Das ging ins Auge, lul.
Haben wir es?
Nice
Sehr gut
So wir nähern uns
Nein nicht wirklich
Ich wollte gerade sagen wir nähern uns dem Ende
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht
Es ist noch ein ganzes Stück bis wir hier durch sind
Wir sind noch nicht mal richtig
Ähm jetzt
Im Namda Komplex angelandet
Wobei doch ich glaube offiziell sind wir schon da
Aber
Ähm
Aber, ähm, also das mit den, das mit den Teleportern und sowas, das fehlt ja noch alles.
Aber es dauert, es dauert schon noch ein bisschen.
Ja, macht ihr mal eure komischen Alien-Sachen, ich verpiss mich einfach.
Ja, ja, ihr dürft, ihr dürft jetzt gerne sterben, Alien-Zeug.
Ja, genau.
Irgendwas passiert, wenn man auf den...
Hab ich das grad schon? Ich glaub ich hab's grad schon ausprobiert.
Es ist nichts passiert, wenn man hier drauf gedrückt hat.
Ah!
Nix.
Oh, schlechte Idee.
Kommt man hier vorbei?
Nein!
Ich glaube, man kann die Dinger ganz gut mit der Brechstange killen.
Irgendjemand von euch da, der zufälligerweise noch nie Half-Life gespielt hat?
Also das Original meine ich, echt?
Ach, Ragnar, du hast noch nie gespielt?
Und? Also ich vermute mal ihr seid ein bisschen jünger. Meint ihr sowas kann man sich 2023 noch geben?
Ich mein das ist halt schon relativ oldschool.
Man kann die einfach auch so killen.
Gameplay ist wichtiger als Grafik.
Das stimmt. Ich muss aber sagen
Half-Life kommt irgendwie so aus der Zeit.
Das sind ja nicht PS1-Graphics.
PS1-Graphic kann man sich nicht angucken, das stimmt.
Aber ich finde Half-Life, gerade mit diesem Software-Pixel-Renderer,
also diesem bisschen pixellichen Software-Renderer,
das geht durchaus klar.
Auch optisch ist das schon noch okay.
Weil das ist jetzt, wow, das ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde, hier ist so quasi
Crysis 4-like
Okay, ich bin so PP-ger für
Okay, wisst ihr was? Wir setzen das jetzt mal gegen die ein
Okay, macht sie blatt. Ich verpiss mich, bis hier alles weg ist. Half-Life VR?
Das ist damals kein vernünftiger PC, also ich kann euch nicht sagen, auf welchem PC ich das erste Mal Half-Life gespielt habe.
Und zwar war das ein Pentium 2 400, relativ sicher, es könnte sein, dass ich auf ein bisschen älterem probiert habe.
Aber ich glaube, das war ein Pentium 2 400, übertaktet auf 450 Mhz und eine ATI 3D Rage Pro, oder wie dieses Ding hieß.
Später dann mit TNT 1, da hatte ich eine Elsa Eraser TNT 1, das war der Shit, also
eigentlich die Grafikkarte, also es war zeitweise die beste Grafikkarte die man sich kaufen
konnte mit TNT 1, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass sie damals glaube ich 250 wahrscheinlich
schon Euro? Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Das war noch vor 2000 Mark wahrscheinlich. Ja, die hat
damals glaube ich 250 Mark oder so gekostet. Und man hat sich gedacht, Alter, 250 Mark
für eine Grafikkarte. Mensch ist das viel. Also Half-Life habe ich mit Freunden zusammen
gespielt der habe ich nicht zugeguckt wo ich wo ich gerne zugeguckt habe es
Also ich war ja schon also bei als kind so immer der nintendo fanboy ich hatte den super nintendo n64 und so zeug
kolleg von mir aus der schule ein freund von mir aus der schule der hatte
von Sega den kram gut da hat er auch einen n64
und bei der habe ich bei den
Bei den Sega games immer zugeguckt und wir haben kennt das noch jemand moment das muss ich euch mal zeigen
Kennt noch jemand Dune Game? Das erste, das Strategiespiel? Das hier? Das da? Dune 2?
Nicht das Buch, das Spiel.
Das war so eines der ersten Echtzeitstrategiespiele überhaupt.
Guck mal, da gibt es sogar... Moment, Remastered?
Ja, so sah das aus.
Du konntest... Nein, nein, du konntest nur einzelne Einheiten auswählen, glaube ich.
Ja, ja, ich glaube, ja, relativ sicher.
Also auf der Konsole auf jeden Fall.
Was du machen konntest ist, du konntest mit befreundeten Einheiten...
Konntest du auf deine Einheiten klicken, dann sind die denen gefolgt.
Das ging.
Du konntest so Ketten bilden, dass dann der eine Panzer dem anderen nachgefahren ist, sondern das haben wir als erstes auf
Auf irgendeiner Sega-Konsole gespielt. Später hatte ich es noch auf dem Amiga
Und die hatten die hatten Sprachausgabe, die haben die haben versucht auf
Auf, auf, was war das, Sega Mega Drive damals, die haben versucht auf der alten Sega-Konsole
Sprachausgabe zu machen für die für die Gebäude und sowas und da haben die versucht in der Sprachausgabe zu sagen
construction finished
und und in deutsch in deutsch haben die dann gesagt
konstruktion fertig nur mit dem unterschied dass die Sprachausgabe so schlecht war dass ich das eher angehört hat wie
Was und irgendwann meinte hat mir mein Freund aus der Schule erklärt dass das heißen soll
Konstruktion fertig.
Wutsch, Wutsch, Wutsch.
Ich mein, es war schon
wahrscheinlich für die damalige Zeit richtig
high IQ, dass sie es
geschafft haben, auf irgendeiner Sega-Konsole
da überhaupt sowas ähnliches wie Sprachsamples
abzuspielen, aber man hat's halt nicht verstanden.
Warum ist das nicht gestorben?
Ja, das sind so Spiele, wo ich sagen muss,
ich finde, die sind nicht so sonderlich gut gealtert.
Gealtert. Wenn man die heute spielt, dann einzig und allein höchstens wegen dem Nostalgie-Faktor.
Also, wenn ich Echtzeit-Strategie-Spiele spielen möchte,
oder Strategie-Spiele, irgendwas, dann würde ich was anderes als Dune 2 spielen.
Und wer auf Oldschool-Sachen spielt, kann sich die Command & Conquer und Alarmstufe Rot Remakes oder Remasters angucken.
Die sind tatsächlich auch ganz gut.
Fand ich jetzt.
Ich bin gerade unschlüssig, ob das der Intended Way war, hier drüber zu hüpfen.
Factorio ist richtig Pock!
Ah, Factorio, glaub mir, in Factorio erkennst du ja wenigstens was.
In Factorio erkennst du, was was ist und das ist quasi sehr viel Detail auf engem Raum,
in Dune 2 erkennst du gar nichts.
Ah, Headcrab. Piss dich alle.
Ist hier ein Fisch drinne?
Oh ja, da ist ein Fisch drin. Nix wie weg.
Okay.
Hier sind Blutegel drin. Gehts weg? Geht ihr weg?
Alle dead. Oh shit!
Der wird mir ja gegrillt, wenn man da hoch geht.
Au!
Und schon...
Schon wieder haben wir keine Leben.
Nice, gut gemacht Max.
Und da ist so ein Fisch drin.
Oh shit.
Okay, ähm...
Mal gucken, ob wir schnell sind.
Ja, wir sind schon- NEIN, NEIN, NEIN, NEIN!
Oh, shit.
Wartet mal.
Okay, erstmal...
Wir killen die Sentry-Gun.
Und jetzt...
Nein.
Wie jetzt?
Wollt ihr mich veräppeln? Das hast du überlebt, oder was?
oder was ja klar
sie betet
ne ok das hat er nicht überlebt
die Fleischkanone hat einen richtig guten dritten Schussmodus
ja hab ich schon gesehen den hier
dann explodieren die Gegner
das hab ich ganz am Anfang ausprobiert als ich die gekriegt hab
als ich die gekriegt habe
So, jetzt müssen wir einen Panzer killen.
So ein bisschen erkennt man hier die Call of Duty.
So ein bisschen erkennt man hier Call of Duty raus, weil in Half-Life war es auch so, immer
wenn Panzer gekommen sind und Helis und Sachen, gab es zufälligerweise vorher Munition für
den Raketenwerfer, so rein zufällig.
Der hat es voll in die Fresse gecrasht.
Panzer-Dätge! Jawoll, nice! So, und jetzt, per Gär haben wir nicht vergessen, dass da unten massig Munition für den Panzer liegt, wir gehen jetzt hier, äh, Anti-Panzer-Zeug liegt, wir gehen jetzt hier runter und sammeln das alles auf, dass wir gleich noch genug haben.
Nehme ich nicht sicher, ob wir das nicht noch brauchen.
Hast du Not a Hero gespielt?
Uuuh, Chatgy hat mich abgelenkt.
Ähm, sagt mir jetzt grad nix, ne?
Ist das was Neues auf Retro gemacht oder irgendwas Neues, aktuelles?
Warte mal, muss ich mal nachgucken.
Not a Hero Game.
Ne, das ist irgendwas Neues auf Steam.
Halbwegs, ne kenne ich nicht.
Irgend so Sidescroller Pixelstelz auf Steam.
2016, ja habe ich gerade gelesen.
Fuck.
Ah, hier sind wir jetzt.
So aufpassen, dass wir nicht in die Pfützen hüpfen.
Ist hier irgendwas?
No pass.
Okay, ich probiere das jetzt mal aus, Chat, weil ihr es seid.
Versuche ich damit jetzt mal einen zu splattern mit dem Ding.
Also wirklich funktioniert das nicht.
Oh, jetzt ist er geplatzt.
Oh, die sind beide geplatzt.
Nicht schlecht, hätte ich nicht gedacht.
Platzke.
Gibt's hier?
Ah, Scheiße.
Schild.
Ihr habt ja irgendwelche so geheimtipps an so Pixelshooter, also sagen wir mal so, dürfen
ruhig modernere Games sein, halt so mit ein bisschen Retro-Look, wo ihr sagt, die sollte
man unbedingt mal gespielt haben, so irgendwas von letzten paar Jahren.
Also mir fällt Against, wie ist das, mit Evil fällt mir ein, das haben wir glaube ich auch mal im Stream gespielt.
Dusk gibt es noch, das neue Warhammer Game, ist auch sehr nice, Boomer Shooter Pixel Retro mäßig.
Ja das wollte ich auch schon immer mal spielen, schon lange wollte ich das spielen, weil ich
mag ja eigentlich so ab und zu mal so irgendwie JRPG angehauchte Sachen, aber nachdem ich
so ein super nintendo kind bin muss man hier die tür mit aufschießen
nachdem ich ein super nintendo kind bin für mich ist chrono trigger immer noch
das beste
das beste jpg der panzer ist ja mal so mies der panzer ist ja so schlecht
Alter
Au
Die lmg verwenden moment ist der lmg drauf keine chance kommen jetzt immer dran
Ich teste nur noch mal ob da wirklich der lmg ist die man benutzen kann aber kann die lmg
Benutzen ja hätte ich das mal gewusst und wir sind wieder bei 18 prozent leben
Wir kommen hier auf keinen grünen zweig
Das ist aber ganz gut, weil hier ist Munition dafür.
Ich glaube jetzt kommen wir in den Lambda-Komplex rein und jetzt kommt diese ganzen Teleport-Rätsel-Spielchen und so, die fand ich ja früher, als ich das Game durchgesuchtet habe, mehrfach, es gab bestimmt Jahre, da habe ich das Game gefühlt zweimal im Monat durchgespielt, 20 mal im Jahr oder so, also wie gesagt, ich habe es total übertrieben, was Half-Life Singleplayer-Kampagne auch angeht.
Früher als das rausgekommen ist
Ja, und das war so ein part der hat mir damals auch immer nicht gefallen
Diese geschichte mit den mit den teleporter rätseln jetzt gleich kommen
Wir probieren jetzt mal was aus guck mal wir machen jetzt das da
Das tatsächlich ganz cool eigentlich müssen wir für diese ganzen kleinen crap mobs monster
Gar keine gar keine munition mehr verschwenden
Die rätsel wurden in plek meser leider stark vereinfacht das stimmt da muss ich aber sagen das fand ich ein paar sind den fand ich jetzt wiederum
nicht schlimm
Er sollte das jetzt nicht eigentlich anfangen runterzufahren ok
Half-Life-Logik, wenn irgendwo was schräg runterfährt, dann fahren wir nicht mit runter, sondern warten, bis es runtergefahren ist und stelzen uns hinterher.
Bei Half-Life-Physics und so, da geht das.
Guckt die bessere Variante.
Kann das mal sterben, please
Okay, die Headcrab will nicht sterben
Wir sparen mal kurz ein bisschen Munition
Nice, guck mal, das klappt ja richtig gut
Au
Wir haben nicht viel Money.
Müsste jetzt nicht noch eigentlich der Raum mit den Assassins kommen?
Der kommt doch noch komplett bevor die Teleporter-Rätsel kommen.
Ach kommt das jetzt?
Ja, wollt grad sagen, das muss doch jetzt irgendwann noch sein, dieser Assassin-Raum.
Oh, hier war was. Irgendeine Headcrab ist an mir vorbeigesprungen. Ich weiß nicht wo. Ach da.
Ich spekuliere ja drauf, dass irgendwo noch ein bisschen Schild und Leben drin ist.
Aber sieht nicht so aus.
Leider.
Da oben gibt es noch ein bisschen was. Die Handgranaten, sehr schön.
Das ist hier nur, falls wir die Armbrust irgendwie verpasst haben.
So, wie gebaiten wir die Assassins? Ich würde sagen so.
Oder die Black Ops Typen.
Das wird spannend. Die haben ja ein bisschen wenig Leben, ne?
So.
Das ist der Raum, Achtung!
Okay, das ist jetzt schon mal richtig pepega gewesen.
Boah!
Ach da!
Alter, bin ich blöd, man!
Okay, das müssen wir anders machen.
Oh shit, oh, oh, rekt, ah shit.
Okay, der hat ge- Okay, lass uns mal kurz in mich gehen.
Wir nehmen jetzt einfach den Raketenwerfer.
Okay, easy.
Pass mal auf. Nein, nein, dann bleibst du auf. Easy. Siehste, wir müssen da taktisch vorgehen jetzt.
Okay, nice. Max ans Trinken erinnern. Sehr gute Idee, mach ich gleich.
Okay, wo sind die Black Ops Dinger?
Okay, da waren schon welche. Die Black Ops Dinger, die werden wir jetzt einfach mit dem Raketenwerfer in die Luft sprengen. Easy.
Komm her. Black Ops Stelz. Jawohl, her komm.
Hier ist noch Leben, sehr gut Sim
Da oben!
Okay, jetzt müssen wir aufpassen
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Shit
Alter, kann man die auch mal treffen?
Okay, wir müssen das anders machen
Wir müssen das einfach hier schnell... Oh Shit
die sind da oben das finde ich aber unfair sie heffen den high ground
Alter ich bin fast dead, gell?
Shit!
Geh auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf, auf,
please!
Waaaah!
Direkt vor der Nase fallen
Okay, wir müssen das so machen. Achtung, she baited
Okay, erster down
Haben die gerade ernsthaft die Kisten zerschossen,
dass meine Granate kaputt geht?
Sehe ich das richtig? Sind die so high IQ?
Da leben noch welche.
Gehe ich jetzt mal von aus, oder?
Ja.
Nice Schild endlich Schild, Schild, Porc Aber da müssten noch ein paar Assassins leben
Endlich mal wieder ordentliche helles vorrat und und schild und alles
Von wo von wo von wo von wo
Moment habe ich gerade getroffen
Hab chat meinte ich habe getroffen
Ich habe Komplett random in die richtung geschossen
Ich glaube der ist der
Ich glaube der ist der moment moment moment
Ja nice ein bisschen glück haben muss man ja auch okay easy easy win nur fünf mal reloaded
Save Reload gets GAMED!
X!
Hier ist doch überhaupt nichts mehr!
Es dürfte doch eigentlich überhaupt nix mehr sein.
Geschafft!
Extrem faster Elevator.
Jetzt benutzen wir wieder das Ding hier, um Ammo zu sparen.
Oh Gott, man kann nicht splattern mit dem Teil.
He, das gefällt mir, das haben sie gut gemacht hier, das einzuführen.
Das ist ja nicht ein Sekundary, was ist das denn? Ein Terzierer Fire Modus.
Träum.
Alles dead.
So, Armbrust raus, gucken was da noch so ist.
Nix mehr? Nix mehr? Alles klar.
Oh, den haben wir schön gescoped. Guck mal, one hit.
Die Fässer explodieren?
Ich glaube diese Fässer nicht, oder? Ach, die auch! Ah, ich dachte bloß die roten.
Soviel zu 35 mal durchgespielt.
Nice, wir haben es geschafft.
Okay, jetzt kommen diese ganzen...
Jetzt kommen diese ganzen Teleporter-Rätselchen und Zeug.
Ohne!
Shit!
Ich dachte man darf den killen jetzt nachdem er aufgemacht hat.
Oder war ich zu schnell?
Weil ich glaube eigentlich braucht man den Typ nicht mehr.
Vielleicht braucht man den aber noch für mehr gleich.
Nö, den brauchen wir überhaupt nicht.
Stellt euch vor, es ist soweit.
Wir haben ordentliche Vorrat Lebensenergie und Schild.
Das hat jetzt nur das halbe Playthrough gebraucht.
Moin Barney.
Ah.
Guck mal, das hat jetzt einen alternativen Feuermodus.
Guck mal, das hat einen alternativen Feuermodus.
Wow, ich weiß nicht, was der Unterschied ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber okay, man kann die aufladen, ich glaube man kann die ein bisschen chargen.
Leider scheren sich beide, also das Ding und das Ding, den gleichen Ammo-Typ.
Nach den Speedruns wird er gekillt, ja vielleicht habe ich aber nicht das richtige Timing gehabt.
Kann durchaus sein.
Moin Abriss Joey!
Ich glaub hier kommt jetzt gleich...
Jaaa!
Wusste ichs doch!
Dass ihr mich jebaitet!
Von hinten GachiBass!
Ja und du auch.
What the?
Nein ich will nicht hochfahren.
Ah ok.
Wie? Überlebt?
Was ist das?
Da sind noch mehr! Ich hör's doch!
Wo sind'n hier noch welche?
Au!
Oh!
Und... Bam!
Dead.
Wo ist das Viech?
Komm her.
Nicht die Headcrab, das andere Viech.
So, in den Reaktorraum müssen wir noch nicht.
So, wir müssen ein bisschen Munition sparen.
Alter Leute, ich bin überfordert, zu viele Waffen.
Oha, den hat's one-shotted.
Das war ein unfairer Spawn. Spawnt direkt hinter einem, ballert einem in den Rücken und rennt dann weg. Ehrenlos hier.
Wie das rumsplattert, ja.
Pass mal auf, guck mal da liegt gar noch niemand.
Das Brecheisen hat nen neuen Modus.
Man kann jetzt ausholen und wenn man dann an die Models rangeht von irgendwelchen Leichen.
Bäm!
Das ist in Black Mesa nicht so krass, dass es so extrem splattert.
Äh, nicht zugehen!
Was ist hier?
Äh, okay.
Warum schießen die aufeinander? Sind die blöd?
Anscheinend.
Hehehehe
Die sind zerlegt an uns.
Oh, da oben ist was.
Oh, da oben ist das andere Viech.
Jawoll.
Next.
Bam.
Down.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Okay, was hier auffällt ist, die Räume sind deutlich kleiner und weniger detailliert als in Black Mesa.
Black Mesa. Ich meine, das ist klar, damit war ehrlich gesagt zu rechnen.
Das ist ja auch alles ein bisschen neuer und das andere ist auf Source Engine und sowas. Aber mir ist es so gar nicht mehr im Kopf geblieben,
wie viel kleiner die Räume sind. Kann man hiermit irgendwas machen? Nee.
Die Black Mesa, also mit Black Mesa die Räume hier waren wirklich eine ganze Ecke größer.
Und auch, und auch mehrschichtiger.
Hört auf hinter mir zu spawnen, alter wie, wo, wo kommt, jetzt reicht es mir aber, jetzt
Jetzt haben sie mich...
Also mit einem HP-Punkt spiele ich jetzt nicht weiter.
Lul.
Totkan ist wirklich sehr random
Meine Güte, ich stelle mich gerade echt da wie der letzte Mensch, als ich das Game noch nie gespielt habe
Aber macht ja nix
Es gibt ja genug Hitpoints und Sachen hier
Nicht so als wär's...
Ne, wir müssen Munition sparen, Zack
Jawoll! Beste!
Oh!
Ist es dead?
Ich glaube es ist dead.
Kann man damit auch die Viecher an der Decke splattern?
Ah nice!
Das gefällt mir, das hat was.
Wir hätten glaube ich mehr
unsere, das machen wir jetzt auch,
benutzen sollen, weil wir kriegen ja
kostenlos Munition.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5
Also die spawnen mir schon gerade
relativ unfair immer im Rücken.
So, wenn ich es richtig in Erinnerung habe, man kann glaube ich
Ich glaube ich hier durchtauchen jetzt nein kann man nicht
Hat er überhaupt einen sinn dass man hier rein kann ne da glaube nicht
Keinen sinn
Fakt ich habe kaum noch munition wir müssen wir müssen glaube ich ein bisschen mehr dieses teil hier benutzen um munition zu sparen
An die Dinger können ja nix.
Guck, zweimal die Bienen draufgeschossen, down.
Moment, hier sind Armbrustpfeile, nice, sehr praktisch.
So, die Reaktorseite haben wir eingestellt.
Das war in Black Mesa, das ist ein viel größerer Akt, da bist du hier ewig unterwegs, bis du
das durch hast.
der
Ich brauche etwas leben das ist
Haben wir nicht irgendwo ein bisschen
Haben wir nicht irgendwo noch ein bisschen was vielleicht rumliegen so
Wo ist denn der Reaktor? Da gab es doch auf jeden Fall Leben ein bisschen hier.
Ne Moment, wo ist denn das? Wo geht es denn hier runter?
Im Reaktorraum gibt es auch viel, das weiß ich noch. Da gab es auf jeden Fall ein bisschen was.
Nice, danke Game. Sehr schön. GG.
Ich glaube das ging sogar da oben lang, wo das Vieh stand.
Den müssen wir jetzt... Bäm? Bäm? Bäm? Dead? Jawoll. Ich glaube hier links. Ja, Reaktor-Access, genau.
Ja. Hier gibt's was. Ja, genau.
Ich meine, viel mehr Leben gibt es hier nicht mehr, ich muss jetzt schon ein bisschen aufpassen.
Hauptsache, da war ein Typ auf der Liege gesplattert.
Und so viele Headcrabs wie hier rumrennen, das ist auch nicht normal.
Da haben die Modgis, die Modhersteller, auf jeden Fall was dran gemacht.
Shotgun, Shotgun, was haben wir hier?
Wow, da machen wir jetzt mal hier.
Hier geht es noch gar nicht lang oder? Ich bin noch gar nicht fertig mit der anderen Quest.
Nennen wir es mal Quest, also mit...
Ist ja gut, ist, ist, ist ja ruhig, ganz, ganz entspannt.
Kriegt euch ab.
Okay, gut, so, wo muss ich hin?
Ich glaube hier links jetzt, genau, hier muss ich lang, wenn es jetzt hier eine Ladezone
gibt, bin ich richtig, ne, hier war ich ja schon, alles gut, alles gut, easy, easy,
So, da sind jetzt Gegner dahinter.
Schnappen wir uns mal das Ding und plastern die weg.
Deadge.
So muss das sein.
War hier irgendwas drin? Nein.
Wow!
Ich seh dich nicht.
Also die Splatter-Effekte haben sie definitiv im Mod überarbeitet, das ist im Original sind die auch ganz schön auseinandergeplatzt, aber nicht so.
Und das finde ich, das passt richtig gut irgendwie zu dem Game.
Sehr nice.
Headcrab? Wusste ichs.
Nee, keine Headcrab.
Zombie.
Wir haben ein bisschen wenig Munition.
Sag das und haut erstmal Munition raus.
Five Head.
Sterben, please.
Ja klar, soviel halte ich ja auch immer aus.
So, ich hoffe es ist alles down.
Weil wir müssen jetzt noch...
Alter, wie ist das zerlegt immer. Ey wir müssen jetzt noch hier die Kühlflüssigkeit oder was das sein soll für den Reaktor einschalten.
Komm her, ich muss Munition sparen. Beweg dich mal nicht zu viel.
Ich glaube jetzt habe ich alles fertig was wir brauchen jetzt müssen wir wieder in den Hauptreaktorraum gehen, dann können wir durchschwimmen
und dann kommen diese blöden Schalter Rätsel, äh nicht Schalter Rätsel, ähm Teleporter Rätsel
wir durchschwimmen und dann kommen diese blöden schalter rätsel nicht schalter
rätsel teleporter rätsel
Chat, wie lange dauert es denn in Half-Life 1?
Es ist nicht so lange wie in Black Mesa, also es sind keine 6 Stunden, aber 1-2 Stunden
Du bist wahrscheinlich schon beschäftigt, ne?
Ne Stunde?
Nee, das dauert schon ein bisschen länger.
Gucken, ob wir das heute noch hinkriegen.
Äh, Game?
So.
Also, wenn ich jetzt richtig liege,
Dann hab ich nicht aufgepasst, aber erstmal möchte ich die Viecher killen.
Oh shit!
Oh nice, mit dem letzten Schuss!
Monka!
X
So, wenn ich jetzt das richtig erinnere, muss man jetzt hier rein springen.
Durchtauchen.
tauchen und dann kommen dann kommen diese ganzen teleporter teleporter dinger
ja genau genau genau
sehr schlau jetzt noch mal ein bisschen munition raus zu raus zu hauen
high IQ
wow
alter wie viel ist denn da los
Okay, da oben zerlegt es irgendwelche Aliens.
Ja genau, jetzt kommen diese komischen Laser- und Teleporter-Spielchen, wo man ein bisschen
gucken muss.
Hauptsache möglichst schnell durch.
Easy.
Nice.
Möglichst schnell durch.
Fast dead.
Dead.
Nice.
Hi ganz ganz schlau
Das spiel sieht so alt aus in das spiel ist 25 jahre alt nun
Aber mit dem mord sieht es tatsächlich besser aus
Wie fair eine headcrab hinter der tür
Wir haben vier Leben
Wenn wir Glück haben, gibt es jetzt noch ein bisschen Leben, sonst sind wir ziemlich aufgeschmissen
Supply
Nice Game
Jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen leben?
Okay, wir müssen klettern.
Das war Plank Master, klar, ich hab's sogar schon mehrfach durchgespielt.
Oh, hallo!
Wo kommt ihr denn her?
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Ich habe das sogar schon das erste Mal durchgespielt, aber war es ganz frisch, noch vor dem Steam-Release.
Da hat der Crossbow in Black Mesa noch so komische Lava-Pfeile verschossen oder so.
Oder sowas. Das ist ja mittlerweile in Black Mesa auch nicht mehr so.
In Black Mesa sind es jetzt eher so Giftspritzen, glaube ich, die der Bogen verschießt.
So am Pullen.
Ah! Endlich!
Bin nicht sicher, ob man hier rüber kann.
Man muss hier rüber können, aber ich glaube das ist so eines der...
Man kommt hier so nicht rüber, das ist wo man mit den Teleportern rein spawnen kann.
Ja.
Dann haben sie den Plague Master vielleicht...
Ich glaub da geht's außen rum.
Wo?
Ist außen ja nix.
Ähm, vielleicht haben sie... Ne.
Half-Life 2... Genau, genau. Half-Life 1 äh Half-Life 2 sind die mit den leuchtenden Bowls und das hatten die ursprünglichen Plague Master auch.
Mr. Freeman.
Mr. Freeman braucht Health.
Okay, wir sparen jetzt mal ein bisschen Muni, guck mal der hat ne Revolver, wo spuckt das
Hier
Wo
Der man ein plan wo das fies ist
Ich bin ich dachte ich dachte ich bin stark
Ich spar mal ein bisschen money dazu muss ich zwar ein bisschen die leichen hier splattern aber gut da gehen wir an
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass der überhaupt hier ist. Ich glaube, der ist mir nie aufgefallen.
Ach, da unten sind die Viecher. Den machen wir mal platt, weil ich glaube,
wenn wir uns da rein teleportieren, ist das Viech immer noch da.
Ja, sehr schlau, Max.
Boah!
Jetzt ernsthaft!
Der fucking Wachmann!
Na gut, ich hab ihm Damage gemacht.
Der taucht noch in voll viel Wasser.
Der taucht schon in voll vielen Levels auf, ja, aber ich glaube hier in den Teleporter reinlaufen habe ich ihn noch nie gesehen.
Ich will das Viech killen, weil ich weiß, dass wir hier nachher mit dem Teleporter reinkommen.
Ist das mal dead?
Kann das mal sterben please?
Ja, nice, down
Okay
Next, Shotgun
Shotgun ist das einzige, wo wir noch ordentlich Ammo haben
Oh shit
Ja, Barney, du machst das schon.
Die Spawns sind mega unfair gerade.
Barney, warst du das?
Warst du das?
Hat er gerade auf mich geschossen?
Was ist da los? Ich brauche die Munition. Ich habe kaum noch, ich habe kaum noch Leben.
Wir sind ziemlich, ziemlich, wir sind ziemlich gefickt gerade was die Held-Situation angeht.
Ich glaube Barney kann eigentlich nichts dafür, das war, weil es jetzt Projektile sind, das ist in seiner AI nicht drinnen. Der denkt halt, dass er Hitscan ist.
Nice, sehr gut.
Leute, wir sind so dead.
Wir sind sooo dead!
Wir sind so dead!
Okay, jetzt kommt...
Okay, hoffentlich, hoffentlich ist hier unten ein bisschen Leben.
Und Muni sparen müssen wir auch
Ammo box ist ja nix
9 und 3 ja geil
Vielleicht hier?
Das wird jetzt was.
Ok, Glück gehabt.
Glück gehabt, ich, by the way, ich hab das noch nie gecheckt, dieses Rätsel, wie das
hier funktioniert.
Ja, nice.
Ja, da ist...
der Etke.
Ich muss glaube ich nach da oben gucken.
Ja.
Oh, hi!
Könnt ihr mich heilen?
Kannst du mich heilen?
Excellent!
Nice Dudes, oder?
Ehrenmänner, wie man so schön sagt heute.
Guck mal wo wir sind!
Auf der anderen Seite.
Die sind so verplatziert immer, die Headcrabs.
Alter, die sind so verplatziert.
What the fuck, Alter.
Okay, nochmal von vorne das Ganze.
Also, zack.
Next.
Ja, sehr schön, sehr schön.
Okay, und jetzt?
Keine Ahnung.
So nicht?
Warte mal, ich bin da zu doof für.
Wo ist denn der Teleporter da oben? Da!
So.
Wait a minute, hier geht's raus?
Ja, das ist sehr fair.
Einfach hinter mir spawnen
Scheiß Viech
Ok, jetzt
Achtung
Hä?
Ok, ich bin glaube ich falsch
Da?
Nein?
Da
Jetzt
Haha
Und jetzt in das, ne
Musste man jetzt hier rein springen in das kaputte?
Ne man musste gucken
Wo das ganz ist
Und dann hat man es geschafft
Alter
So jetzt kommt nochmal so ein komisches Ding
So
Und jetzt
mal so ein komisches Ding. Nice. Och Gott, ich bin so unfähig, was so Hüpfereinnahmen
angeht. Wait up. Jump Skills, ja, Massive Jump Skills. Ok, jetzt geht das auf. Das schauen
mal richtig
Okay, die zwei haben wir da ist die eins da müssen wir jetzt hin
So geschafft jetzt müssen wir nur noch da rein hüpfen gleich
Übrigens, falls ihr es noch nicht wusstet, so funktioniert ein Atomkraftwerk.
Wenn ihr euch schon immer gefragt habt, wie das da innen drin aussieht und funktioniert,
ist quasi Simulator hier.
Wo kommt man jetzt hin, wenn man da reingeht?
Wieder runter!
Jaja, ist klar. Na, da will ich natürlich hin.
Sehr schlau, dort einen Ladetrigger hinzusetzen.
Five-Header-Time.
Ja, das ist sehr fair. Okay, was genau soll ich dagegen jetzt machen?
Das kann doch jetzt nicht euer Ernst sein, dass das so funktionieren soll, oder?
Einfach verstecken, just, just, nicht, nicht, Gameplay, einfach, einfach umgehen.
Beste Idee.
Die Sounds der Headcrabs, die werde ich auch nicht vergessen, also die Half-Life Sounds,
die werden mir immer im Kopf bleiben.
Oh!
Müssten wir eigentlich...
Ja, wir sind durch!
Also, nicht durch das Game, aber durch diese
Rätselstelz-Dinger
Jetzt kommt...
Das ist jetzt kurz vor...
Du hast ein Headcrab-Stofftier
Ja
Sollte ich mir vielleicht auch mal holen, sowas
Ich hab ne Half-Life-Kappe bestellt
Wenn ihr in Frankfurt einem in der Half-Life-Kappe rumrennen seht, bin ich das.
Bin wahrscheinlich der Einzige.
Oh, was'n das?
Was'n das? Das ist normalerweise nicht hier.
Oh, neue Waffen.
Pogu, Pogu.
So dann holen wir uns mal hier wieder volle Muni, volle Muni, volle Muni, volle Muni,
Langsprungmodul brauchen wir noch.
Passende Headcrab-Mütze, ja das wäre ganz witzig.
Es ist ziemlich unpredictable, wie es auslöst, aber okay, nice.
So, Boss, wobei, es gibt keinen Bosskampf so wirklich an der Stelle jetzt, es sind einfach
nur viele Gegner.
Mal gucken, ob wir das hinkriegen.
Ich will eigentlich Longjumpen da oben drauf, aber das geht nicht.
doch geht alles
auf
wie in der IT-Welt
das sieht ganz okay aus aber hier ist er naja okay es geht eigentlich ich meine besser
ich könnte jetzt den stream neu starten aber ich glaube das passt schon
übrigens was wisst ihr was ich jetzt mal mache wir machen
und ducken auf shift und alternate auf shift gibts nicht was nein nein nein jump ist space
geht gleich viel besser bitchraid kannst du ohne neustart hochstellen nee kann ich nicht
Weil ich NVN verwende.
Geht das? Wirklich?
Ich glaube nicht, dass das geht.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Tatsächlich?
Seit wann geht denn das?
Früher musste man immer den Stream neu starten dafür.
Okay, nice.
Nice, okay.
Okay.
Nice.
Was?
Ja, mach mal.
Mal gucken.
Mal gucken, was die Waffe überhaupt macht.
Ist das das Ding von Opposing Force?
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie das Teil, was man in Opposing Force kriegt.
Du du du du auf kollege ok
Okay, das ist immer noch brutal, oder?